[Music]
[Applause]
welcome everybody september 2nd it's
september
it's supposed to be cooling off but it
is hot
today
it's so hot we have the ac blaring so if
i'm in a schvitz you know why
that's hot we have uh no sponsors of
course today
[Applause]
but we are joined they're missing out
yeah i know that's what i always think
too but we are joined today by pokeman
[Applause]
let me explain them
don't worry about it so i always tell
people like just call me pokey
so you don't have to worry about it but
essentially my name is iman i am annie
yeah so when i first made my gamer tag i
was like oh i love the game pokemon and
my name iman so i was like pokemon so
that's what it's kind of supposed to be
but obviously when you read it as an
english speaker it reads like pokeman so
i don't mind when people say that wait
is it not pokeman pokemon out of
everything oh so it does say it is
pokemon it's like pokemon i made it with
the intention to be
right what i don't mind if people say
pokemane because that's what most people
say oh we need a nintendo lawsuit up in
this [ __ ] you they're very litigious
no i every time i say that i'm also like
so i'm okay with pokemon because i'm not
trying to catch a nintendo lawsuit i
don't know because i know they
got some time yeah for sure
okay before we get too deep into it i
just want to say because we have a
sponsor
ela you can introduce this
okay
we have daddy fresh our classics
line came up and um
i personally
really love the color palette here it's
like this washed out they all have this
amazing wash um
pigment dye wearable yeah very wearable
nice tone i'm wearing the
women's like shrunken
and she looks amazing in it wow
and he looks amazing in it wow luxurious
wait hold on any legend
damn
looking like majin buu from this angle
[Laughter]
i said looking like majin buu from this
angle i don't know who the [ __ ] that is
he's a legend just pull up a picture
pull up a picture pull it up pull it up
pull it up
i'm sorry but like i'm just not gonna
stand with this a b flat pokeman got it
okay
who the [ __ ] is manju boo oh
dragon ball z
okay all right you're fired bro get the
[ __ ] out
it's a very cute reference i will say
he's a beloved character yeah i'm sure
as are you ethan
abe pretends like he's the same and then
he makes me look bad every episode
no you're awesome i'm trying to make
your show funny
yeah okay
zach you're the ship babies love you i
think whoever is the best stamp we
should swap their tables like they
should come closer
oh
i like that idea
anyway today we're gonna do it like
obviously we're joined by pokemon
actually can i steal the show for a
moment yeah go ahead
all right
i want to preface by saying
long time big time fan
with peace and love for like six years
oh wow i've been watching crazy
yeah since i was in college
still streaming part-time me and my
roommates anytime you guys would drop a
video this was back in like the vape
nation days and like um kind of like
more reactionary content stuff
and every time you guys drop a video we
would all get together as roommates and
put it on the
tv that's awesome and it's been amazing
seeing you guys transition to like live
stream podcast content seeing ela create
teddy fresh and then like
pour her literal heart and soul into it
and make it such a massive company like
just wow business woman thank you
deserves all the love in the world
um yeah i think you guys are so cool
amazing thank you and
i know like you know there's there's
haters for everybody
right i
me too me too man
but i think especially when you start
streaming like you just say so much of
course at some point like there are
takes that maybe i don't agree with that
you probably don't agree with that you
used to say like oh yeah but that
doesn't mean we can't come together for
hopefully a beautiful entertaining show
wait what have i said let's talk about
it wait
take the compliment first oh oh i don't
know let's go it's like well let's let's
get to the heart of it oh my god thank
you so
much you're so so nice get right into it
and thank you
we've always had only
support and appreciation to you as well
yeah
a female
little streamer women the biggest the
biggest female women in the in the
gaming industry yeah it's hard out here
it's they're they don't like to see us
women
succeed they don't want us they really
don't that's true
we have a lot of respect for you and
we've we pretty much align on everything
so
we've always been a supporter of you we
love seeing you in the chat and it's
going to be a fun episode
let's get it and what dbc character does
she look like
i don't think anyone on dbc really has
curly curly hair i was just gonna say i
told you off-screen but i will say it
here too your hair looks amazing thanks
and
took a lot of courage oh here we go
[Laughter]
now they're saying i look like kirby i
mean guys
can i catch a break
but he's the cutest i didn't
i'm doing my best here this angle don't
make anyone look but he's the cutest
ethan
okay he's such a legend but do you want
to [ __ ] kirby
um someone out there surely does there
it is
everyone
[Laughter]
gabe hey what's up buddy you're looking
good man it's hot it's so hot it's so
hot outside the coffee's like it's
enough to fry an egg i'm gonna crack an
egg on the concrete let's see how it is
okay that's interesting we're doing a
little science experiment with gabe here
oh
oh let me see that oh maybe a black
surface would have worked better but
that's okay don't you do it like in a
pan i hear some sizzling it's friday
baby
friday baby [ __ ] yeah what you doing
today
[Applause]
pissing my dick [ __ ]
in my dick [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i heard you come out with a new one on
tick on instagram or tick tock it was um
oh yeah hey you do you have that one and
you do it
how are you doing it's friday baby
how's the egg show me the egg
let's get a close-up
any movement
nope um
i don't see a lot of movement no is it
cooking at all or no can we get a
close-up
what do you think you're sizzling right
yeah do we hear sizzling gabe i think i
hear sizzling
it's not hot enough but it's like hot
outside it's like 110.
oh
[Applause]
gabe do you this is pokey mane he's a
twitch streamer do you want to say hi to
her
yeah
he knows yeah
whoa the pokemon
pokemon in my mind
i got a pokemon in my butt
let's catch up with the ball baby
yeah boy yeah boys
are you
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the best way to start a friday
there's no other friday warm-up gabe you
got any plans this hot beautiful summer
weekend
yeah three days weekend it's a long
weekend it's like four day weekend
starting today friday saturday sunday
and monday wednesday
what's off about today you just don't
work or what
oh friday's kind of like everybody's
chokes for a three day weekend so friday
saturday sunday and then the bonus is
labor day
[ __ ] yeah be it
gabe i'll be meaning to ask you
isn't techn i mean do you you don't have
like a job right i mean you do cameo
the cameos i do like other things too
oh you you do have a work
because the whole concept of a weekend
is kind of interesting for you because
yeah i think it's like it's like
everybody has to have a day out to enjoy
their life out of work you know [ __ ]
everyone has a weekend for him
[Applause]
baby do have a day job you work during
the week
not not really
[Laughter]
this is my job
it's friday every day baby yes sir
friday [ __ ]
i see the power breakers behind you is
the power stable in your house you guys
doing okay
we're good
we are good okay good got a lot of fuel
and stuff for like 110 it's almost like
vegas baby
you got any big plans this weekend or
nah
i get some hookers baby
[Applause]
oh someone gave it to me
someone gave you one and you just go
with it
yeah
okay what's your favorite sexual
position may i ask
maybe maybe
maybe the doggy style or the stretch
open leg position in the front
all right hold on very specific like
spread eagle dang okay okay gabe let's
get after it this weekend
all right all right
you have a good time with those hookers
and stay cool okay bud
all right
how's the egg egg
well
it lives
yeah how you do what's your plan to
clean that up by the way you're just
gonna leave it
if it's not gonna fry then i'll just
pick it up yeah yeah you can i see one
can i watch
bts i just you know i just would like to
see that i think it could be interesting
yeah we got a drum roll for you gabe
yeah yeah so
so we are traveling through the uh
living room headed to what looks like
the kitchen
yep what are we looking for are you
gonna use a glove
paper towel paper towel okay good good
choice
now is that what you would pick use
pokey a paper towel what would be your
technique on this the yellow honestly
there's got to be layers to it maybe you
get some of it with the paper towel but
then you have to use like water some
kind of cleaner
you got to hold it down let me see maybe
after the show pose it yeah let me see
what's going on down there gabe oh yeah
i think you're right pokey you need to
kind of
not cook my bud not quite
wrong
consider how much he's doing for the
content of his podcast
he always delivers he really does gabe
we love you you have a great weekend
okay bud
appreciate it
have a good
labor day weekend
thank you what happened your eye
again in my eyes
so i can get in my eyes because it's so
sweating outside because it's so hot
right
[ __ ] my [ __ ] belly button [ __ ]
[ __ ] my [ __ ] armpit and squeeze it
down [ __ ]
[Music]
thank you gabe thank you very much
all right all right buddy
right here baby we love you
all right bye gabe
all right
i love you ciao
what was that
[ __ ]
ciao
[Applause]
but it turned into like a wolf house or
like a wolf man it does something for
the soul you know absolutely man that's
why we have them on every friday just
you can't beat it wait i remembered one
other thing i wanted to mention
frenemies was so
iconic for internet culture man
i know it's a chapter you guys closed
but i gotta say
just because it's something i think you
guys should always be proud of you know
especially because it was during the
pandemic oh my god is that something i
looked forward to
every single damn week thank you i think
it was a special show i mean it really
it was a lot of people bonded with that
show and i
i'm very proud of that chapter it's just
that there's a lot of
it's just kind of insane
as you know
the way people on twitch would say that
borderline scripted you know oh people
thought well people were accusing us of
faking it
but trish is about to know you then
because that's
you know i would never
ever i know i would never even joke
especially in relation to family it like
i don't think you guys would ever cross
those lines no bro i'm are you kidding
me it's like
i would never joke about it let alone
let it happen i mean [ __ ]
but but either way i think remember it
for the good thing that it was yeah i'm
for so
like
millions of people it still gets a lot
of views people still go back and watch
the episode which is pretty incredible
yeah
but um
yeah she's about to have that baby which
is kind of insane she's about to have a
baby photo yesterday she was like posing
yeah she's due like in any week here now
which is pretty insane
right guys
olivia yeah yeah we're sitting we're
just getting to move on
[Laughter]
yeah thank you joe so before we get too
deep into this we actually do have a
surprise for you
we're so happy to have you here i don't
know if you know our crew member in
sweden his name is love i know everybody
here thank you well great guys
anyone's names like i know
the love bot
suffered a grievous wound
and he hasn't been in his lovebot
recently he's just been on that monitor
behind a b
oh i see and people have been missing
lovebot yeah him walking around or
rolling around
rolling around and rolling around you
know we really miss
we really miss his presence in the
office
but most of all
he's he's got into the broken love bot
because he's a big fan and he wanted to
say hi to you so lovebot is here
we fired him back up
uh just for her bring him out bring him
out yes yeah we have a whole uh
a package to show the process of um
surviving him okay so here is kind of
the behind the scenes of us preparing
lovebot
to uh meet you his one of his favorite
streamers
i'm honored
so whenever you guys are ready
we'll roll that
i don't know yeah i don't know there's
this not really working
what what's what what's not working what
are you talking about
i don't know like
this new love belt it's so bulky like i
feel like a furniture just in the corner
of the room no don't say that no no no
no you're important like part of this
crew i was just warming up to it to be
honest yeah
i don't know i feel like just it's just
so fat and bulky and i compliment your
skinny legend
stop talking about yourself like that
it's okay yeah this is coming from
what's up bud it's okay i don't know
like
i i know pokemon is coming tomorrow and
stuff like that
right yeah
that's what it is
yeah you know i just want to be like
more presentable on something 100 of all
known for sure i don't know you guys
know i'm a big fan of some uh stuff like
that i don't know just
just doesn't feel right
i see i see what this is yeah well
listen
i feel bad suggesting this it's a little
dangerous it's dipping into the dark
arts a little bit but there's a few
things i could maybe do for you to
spruce you up a little bit oh really
at this point dude whatever whatever
dude i'm i'm over this you have you have
to do something dad okay
let's do this
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
let's get to work
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hype train
hype train
yes
it's not working thank you for the
gifted
thanks for the gifted
[Music]
it's finished
yes so
against all the odds
and at great length and effort we have
revived a brand new new and improved
love bot 2.0 back
just
how do you feel now to be back in a
revived love box oh i'm so happy i'm
almost a real boy uh
and uh
i think this counts yeah i'm very
excited though what's up hello hello
pokey you have something in your hand
there my god is that for me
yeah maybe
yeah
i'm trying to take it
obviously you've been building towards
this for a while now is there something
you want to you want to say hi to your
favorite creator you mean you haven't
used the little picture of you
you probably noticed right yes
okay i was actually okay you want to
know how big of a fan i am i not only
watch your podcast i watch it with my
friends in discord so me and my friend
yeah we'll just like shout out a little
screen share yeah shout out kent he's a
homie we'll screen share your podcast
and like watch it at the same time and
when we first saw that pop up he was
like hey yo it's you
that's funny
it is me so thank you i feel like a free
sponsor oh
thank you and thank you
well thank you you know that's your
chance uh i mean you're probably not
going to get another chance so i don't
know right exactly so i want to start
off by saying you know thank you for
streaming and entertaining me over the
years you know i
i've been on twitch forever you know i'm
actually a world of warcraft andy so
i've been on twitch forever you know
yes it's the
you know so i've been here
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah yeah he's a big
time twitch guy he loves all the twitch
he watches everybody
yeah
he streams at the same time
or during our show not at the same time
but like afterwards i'll be like i'm
going live right because you do go fast
you do go live pretty fast after the
show
i don't notice that
you're right he does do that
you're actually right love you do do
that don't lie that is not true but that
is totally different we noticed that
before where he went called out
that's okay that was a b the show that
was a b
i never okay hold on
that was me i'm sorry that was me but
yeah i was on vacation at the time and i
thought you were done because you said
this ending just happened
all right all right you know actually
just to go on a side note here and to
create it myself i actually take very
big precautions to make uh
it not like a a tree after show you know
i want to make anything uh
yeah you want to do your own thing right
yeah you know and i don't want to like
uh
piggyback on ethan's success or anything
like that so yeah you know i respect
that
oh
yeah thank you so much for the love and
support love you the best well thank you
very much and yeah uh as i said uh i
think for the countless hours of
entertainment and i think i have a
another another little gift on me
somewhere i don't actually know exactly
where it is
oh there it is
oh great so yeah
i
smart my word i will put this up on my
stream
[Applause]
are you doing a duck face
something here um
deep lore hit him with some deep lord i
bet he knows it
oh no i mean
i'm not sure about that what was the
first game that i streamed
uh
i don't know
i don't know you can guess it
wait what do you ask him just give it
again the first game that i streamed
like what i initially started my
streaming career off of can i guess even
though i don't know
yeah it was probably league league yeah
yeah league of legends uh i was giving
you a few that was a song
i'm second thinking this no no please
poke you one more okay one more try one
more time nervous um
okay this one's maybe easier what's my
uh ethnicity
um moroccan okay okay okay we'll get
another one
i've been to morocco
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
congratulations on the new love bot
yeah that old love bot was absolutely
destroyed we were looking for a good
opportunity to unveil the new love bot
so ah this is the perfect one you got it
right he can move again
i can't get over the little hands and
feet
someday
hopefully you guys can like animate it
somehow oh my god
just like a puppeteer kind of thing
i hope i hope it's not weird for me to
call this out but someone donated ten
dollars for iman's jeep fund which i
didn't know i stopped at you guys
that's guys we don't have fun we don't
need another jeep let's get pokey that
jeep guys do not buy that jean
yeah not for me give it to olivia anyone
else anyone else sam
i don't need a jeep fund okay yeah
they're they're doing a gag on us guys
give it to sam please get it
so um let's move on to obviously one of
the big topics i want to talk about
today which i haven't talked about ooh
andrew sent us a cease and desist
i think i saw that on twitter yeah he's
threatening to sue me no if i don't stop
talking about him which obviously i'm
not complying uh right now
so we'll get into oh i remember you
saying it's so funny that everybody
tries to talk about like free speech
when it comes to de-platforming him and
then he sends you a cease and desist
which is a little it's a little better
it's not adding up here a little bit of
a soy boy situation if you ask me odd
yes yeah so i have the the letter he
sent us which i'm going to read but
before we get into stuff oh i haven't
even seen the letter myself oh yeah yeah
it's good
as you can read it i'm gonna put it up
we're all gonna enjoy it
yeah he doesn't know me very well i mean
who thinks that doing a legal threat
against me is
the vibe
oh yeah but also against anyone who can
afford to speak to a lawyer yeah
just doesn't make sense
they have no grounds for a cease and
desist
well he said he's saying i defamed him
by saying he's a human trafficker but
the problem with that is that oh i know
he is a human trafficker
i know all about defamation claims
so
do you get those
oh my god you don't know
you guys don't know what happened bruh
okay how about we talk about this um
after because yeah you know how i
mentioned the
ninja disappearance thing yeah i feel
like that could be interesting let's
talk about it no
and then i'll i'll bring that up out oh
you talking about how his wife
threatened yeah yeah but did that ever
return to anything no but even then like
essentially threatening to sue me for
definition not even essentially like
verbatim that was that was a lot you
know that that was yeah i didn't know
why they had to take it so far i don't
know either
it is what was it what was even for i
don't even remember what was the
situation so on my stream
okay essentially when gideon did the
whole thing on twitch
ninja on his stream
pretended to speak to his twitch rep and
try to get them unbeaten something like
that right and
then they try to act like that never
happened so on my stream i showed a clip
of it happening and i was like i don't
know if he actually did text the person
or if he just because he lit he grabs
his phone he's like that's not the tech
yeah yeah yeah so i just played the clip
and i was like this is what happened and
this is what they're telling me which
they're they were essentially trying to
gaslight me anyway so they saw that and
they were like anything you say from
here on out we will consider
defamation and you will be hearing from
our lawyers and then i just posted
through dms yeah cause i was like oh i
don't like this no that was good you did
that that was so stupid that they did i
think once you went public they realized
what a stupid thing it was to say i
think what was really bothersome to me
is like even just as someone who's like
a law and order fan
i think anyone who knows anything about
law
or even as a content creator like you
know defamation has to involve like
first of all you saying a lie
and second of all you knowing that it's
a lie
me playing your clip that you deleted to
hide evidence on my stream is is not me
lying no it's yeah
you're very you're weird most people
don't know that actually i think people
just use it as a way to scare
and they think it will work and you know
what's sad is that it probably does work
for example
yeah yeah yeah yeah it just makes me sad
to have seen someone that i respected at
a point
like just use tactics like that i really
really did not expect it yeah so here's
the new pokemon just in case you were
wondering
looking pretty good i of course
jigglypuff is that who i am so good or
some am i wiggly tough uh i believe that
that is
wait maybe that's is that clefairy no
that's jigglypuff that is ugly puffy
okay i'm a little so so i know my
pokemon you do pokemon you're pretty
good
decent yeah thank you very much and
here's good enough the two trainers
you guys just tell me who to fight
so what did you ever uh make a case with
ninja and justin no okay yeah so when we
were gonna talk about it i was gonna
give my opinion but also say you know it
might be a little biased because i am
evidently not the biggest fan are you so
you're i you know i draw the line at
threatening to sue me yeah yeah yeah you
could do a lot of [ __ ] but that one i'm
like ah maybe we shouldn't be homies so
there's still some negative feelings
yeah yeah obviously
you know it just is what it is you just
got ties we're not we're not like close
in terms of social circles or anything
like that so i don't really hear from
him
i see you a lot with my girl my bella
yeah that was such a sweetie yes
so you want so we're talking about the
current event it was which ninja just
had
did we i don't think we ever showed it
on the show why don't we pull up the
clip of his final moments no it just it
was yesterday was it after uh leftovers
yeah so we we've been doing this thing
we've been trying to make good with
ninja because i was pretty mean to him
in the past yeah i saw you guys had he
sent you something
he had g fuel send us a bunch of [ __ ]
which is funny and we got a bunch of
rare i'm still not sure if he knew he
was sending it to us because these guys
were taking the lead on simping for him
i think oh no i did i did i talked to
him yeah we love as well right love's a
huge ninja family i don't know and loki
i was like
you know
you gotta pick one or the others
no no listen listen i will drop nina uh
any day for your stream yeah it's okay
i'm not gonna make you choose
no you need this you didn't have to and
i did it anyway noted moment you know
yeah actually
i'll say this we have a sponsor coming
up
gamer sub you know about that
the real so i've met them they're
becoming a sponsor and so now g-fuel is
known as lead fuel
okay because there's lead in it
there was like a gamer fuel controversy
where uh yeah they found leaders
but it was like a negligible amount just
just to be fair so they don't kill me
yeah yeah yeah a standard standard let's
take it one last bit at a time but i
like to call it lead fuel technically
there's light in it
technically
for speaking technicalities maybe let's
not take that as our war pain it's war
now now that we're gamer sub family
do you have any you're with them or
you're against them um no
i just
yeah never mind go ahead
listen when it comes to these like drink
uh companies
and like what do you call them powder
caffeine yeah what are actually energy
energy powder powders
there's quite a few of them
especially within the gaming community
thank you so much
and i personally thank you so much
i personally have avoided affiliating
myself with anyone or any company that
affiliates with people
that i just think are not good for the
internet
because i'm like
i think it says a lot as a brand and
company who you affiliate with sure
i don't want to be in close proximity
with those people are you talking about
one and specific that you want to uh i
might i think the people at home can
piece it together you know
is this about lead fuel thank you oh my
god do you want a soda pop
are you talking about uh can i say
what's on my mind sure or should we just
avoid it um
i'll ju i'll just sit and nod
but you can say whatever if i'm reading
between the lines you are anti-lead fuel
because they sponsored keemstar for a
long time
who is basically uh the reincarnation of
uh
i will say i'm not biased
i'm not
anyone
again it's just like if you affiliate
with people that maybe
that i just there aren't that many
people that are content creators that
i'm really just big no-nos on yeah
but if you're homies with them i just
don't want to be involved that's true
man shout out that's the truth about it
i mean don't take your money or your
mouth you know right i'm glad they
dropped his ass a long time ago but your
very truth i mean i mean you're very
true on that sorry but um sorry
i love the sound effects
yeah i say lead fuel by the way it's a
negligible amount of lead i just want to
make that clear because okay you're just
making a joke they consume me right but
if i'm not clear about that which i
don't want that's why i want you to make
it clear yeah don't i'm not defaming
lead fuel here don't get me wrong i'm
not saying it's bad amount of lead i'm
just saying they're sliding it there was
and maybe i'm saying also there wasn't
lead in it before they started working
with keemstar
maybe the lead came in
you know since the cotton candy flavor
came out you proved it
allegedly not just a joke for legal
purposes
clear uh throat clearing
wait someone want me to mucus
well there were multiples
oh you want me to stop saying lead fuel
you're getting messages from our
attorney
yeah i'll just clarify on behalf of the
table
we don't know anything about whether or
not there is or isn't it lead in jesus
we really don't know
it's a thing ethan might have heard if
you want to know the facts we recommend
you do your own research right no shade
to g-fuel any other company
the affiliation is gamer subs officially
on the h3 podcast thank you very much
[Applause]
i think our sponsorship with them starts
next week so it sure does we're already
paying it forward and they're getting
dividends already they really are
gamers
less lead than g fuel baby
anyway
so
yeah ninja put out this cryptic or i
don't know it's not cryptic but i don't
know that i believe him he put out this
uh he was streaming
fortnite like you do
and then he got mad and laughed and then
he said i actually didn't see this oh
you saw sweetness i haven't seen
anything this is final moments on uh
stream okay
yeah here let me turn up the quality
here
if i can please oh max 360 okay
did they rift
now i don't know if the hell is that why
does everybody understand what's
happening here i don't know why he's
angry so the enemies basically
teleported away why is that bothering
him so much is that part of the game
yeah yeah maybe you could break it down
for me sure
[Music]
ah so he was about to like lazy like he
was about to kill them yeah and then
they used i guess an ability a thing
where you can just like
fly up into the sky further teleport
away and then fly elsewhere yeah so
i guess to him they're using a mechanic
that he finds annoying to
run away but it just seems like let's
watch the rescue yeah it seems like he's
overreacting you'll see
what the hell is that why is it ripped
in the middle of the sky
ninja
he's lost can't do any more dude i can't
that's teleport bro
i'm [ __ ] sick of this dude
i'm sick of these [ __ ] players
spamming rip to goes everything i i i
haven't had enough man i'm not even
[ __ ] kidding dude i've had enough i
can't even i'm not even i'm i'm leaving
no way i'm
i'm done
i'm done i'm fact i'm honestly dude i'm
not even gonna i'm not even gonna i
gotta take a break from streaming dude
i'm gonna [ __ ] i'm gonna lose my
[ __ ] mind bro
i'm sorry i know i know we're supposed
to play all day i i can't
oh my goodness i'm sorry i'll i'll talk
to the other side
chad i don't know i don't know when i'm
gonna be live man i don't know where i'm
gonna be live next but i gotta
i gotta get off man
yes so the part that's throwing people
off to think it's fake is he says i
don't know where i'm gonna be live next
why do you have to be mad it's just a
game
this was the last time
that's well it happened like yesterday
okay and then he's like yo then you put
out tweets let's see here
uh where are these
uh uh uh are these in the doc guys
yeah here it is
so he tweeted out here
um
he said i just need to change his
username to user not found very dramatic
very dramatic can i teleport really set
you off that much
i've got opinions on this okay
where shall i start well he says i need
a break i don't know when i'll be back
or where which seems like he's obviously
baiting that he's yeah i think and also
what i've heard mind you this is from
someone in my chat so
someone please correct me if i'm wrong
or look into it for sure i heard that
his contract is up in september so like
his streaming contract is up now
and he might have not chosen which
platform he wants to go to yet i see and
on his final stream
he happened to get upset and he was like
effort i'm just going to end it here
in this manner so it was real you think
i think
i think he was planning to do this whole
twitter thing likely but i think he just
took this opportunity of like oh i'm so
annoyed and this is my last day anyways
like let me just
kind of dramatically end okay that's
interesting what do you i mean you guys
are the ninja uh uh
i don't know enough about it but that
sounds plausible yeah and to add some
more context he lost his uh verified
badge right after on twitch his partner
badge what does that mean
i think that ascen that means he's no
longer partnered which could mean one of
two things
so usually if you renegotiate with
twitch and you stay with them you will
retain that verification badge the whole
way through
he might be in a phase where he's like
i'm ending my contract and i'm just not
i'm just not going to decide
where i'm going
for like a month so i'm no longer
partnered anywhere
but the alternative which is also kind
of likely
is that he's already signed a deal with
like youtube or somewhere else and they
know they found out not just they find
they already like they have to know
right
right anyways and that's why they
removed his thing and i think he's using
this
i think he's using this to like build
hype for his return right because this
is something that a lot of people have
done including myself like prior to
renewing your contract you're like guys
i'm gonna go on break and then i'll
announce where i'm going what i'm doing
blah blah blah mm-hmm so yeah so he
might be moving because if he was gonna
resign with twitch i don't think they
would have immediately taken away his
sub button until they found out for sure
that he was going elsewhere don't you
think it's a little corny when twitch
does that though even if he is going
there it's like why you got to be so
vindictive like we had to deal with
twitch back back back back in the
beginning of our podcast where we were
live streaming there and then we decided
to start doing it on youtube and they
they like
they like nuked our channel where they
still owed us money
and they're like oh you have to reapply
to to be a partner to get first to pay
you i was like are you [ __ ] crazy it
just seems like so [ __ ] up the way
that they do that it's i think
twitch does a lot of things
wrong only because it's a large company
with a lot of people a lot of hands blah
blah blah um
but as does youtube to be fair youtube
messes up a ton too
with copyright or whatever it is
um however
i think in a situation like this
twitch doesn't want to take away ninja
sub button like they want to continue
making money off him as long as they
possibly can so i highly doubt that
they're doing this in a vindictive
manner i think they're doing this
because they legally have to because
he's he might have already started a
contract but that's what i'm saying they
have that people himself asked him or if
he himself was like can you guys take
away my sub button so that people don't
know where i'm gonna go live next
yeah i don't think this is a situation
where like it is financially in their
best interest to keep his butt that's
what i think too but they did the same
thing to me it just seems like
vindictive i think with exclusivity
contracts like if someone isn't getting
paid extra and they're just a partner on
twitch
they give you a lot of leeway but if
they're paying you to stream on their
platform
that's when they're more which i'm
assuming you guys were also exclusive to
them beforehand yeah yeah so as soon as
you end an exclusivity contract not just
a partner contract that's when they're
like oh we have to take away those
benefits yeah okay well whatever it's
really it's just company stuff it's
finance they're doing they're doing
everything they can for their financial
benefit understandably so
well g fuel needs to or i mean let this
is their new flavor by the way i heard
that keemstar is coming back and they're
giving him this one lead fuel ladies and
gentlemen
extra lead
unlike their normal formulation which is
negligible amounts of blood but
keemstars will grow purposes this is a
joke yeah but
keemstars will give your brain uh
your brain damage and uh birth defects
anyway
uh moving on
so that's exciting what do you guys
think about that though because you guys
are like ninja scholars you guys like
his move to youtube
all
right
sam
yeah
yeah i mean those are the ninja scholars
yeah you said his move to youtube which
i think is pretty much confirmed right
um yeah i mean i don't know
we'll see i'm everything pokemon said
seems spot on like and also he tweeted
before his stream big things are coming
so
seems like he was all set up
at first i kind of thought
oh at first i kind of thought that they
were going to resign with twitch but
after what you said pokey like it's not
really in their best interest to unsub
him so maybe it doesn't make sense for
him to resign with twitch
it'll probably go better than his
transition to a mixer though
yeah i don't see that dude that was the
best deal anyone ever got though that
mixer thing
all right well moving on past that uh
actually i will say if it's of interest
to anyone i'm happy to spill the tea on
so many streaming things like personally
for me if you're a really large-scale
creator and you have over like a million
followers on twitch
i think unless money is your main motive
it's better to remain both on twitch and
on youtube
whereas if you move
if you move you're just taking away one
massive social platform reach that you
have well before twitch would not let
you do both right until recently only if
yeah yeah yeah
honestly
i'm trying to think if i am able to say
this i think i'm able to speak my
opinion even though i'm with twitch i
think long term the best thing for
any large creator is to have is to
utilize as many platforms as possible
so i actually hope that over time
exclusivity contracts kind of die down
and people just have
sub buttons and memberships on all
platforms everywhere are you talking
about like multi-streaming to like both
platforms at the same time right because
some people prefer twitch some people
prefer youtube why should you have to
that's true exactly some a lot of twitch
viewership don't watch youtube as much
but youtube taps into yeah exactly so
you want to be able to reach obviously
both demographics if you can yeah
so are you allowed to do that now can
you multi-stream to both platforms or
not twitch recently made a change where
they allow partners
not people under exclusivity contracts
but partners
are able to stream on tick-tock
that's weird
i think it's because they noticed that
doing that actually brings in a lot more
viewership to twitch right because i've
seen a lot of people
just kind of show their stream on tick
tock and they're like come watch me here
and it actually increases their
viewership interesting yeah the tick
tock lives there's a lot of transient
views just constantly coming and going
when you do those that's the format
translate from like the white screen to
that yeah
dude tick tock is such a freaking wild
place man
uh that's interesting
um okay so
if you've got more
so let's see
um
let's move on to the next thing we got
here we got love bot
um
okay i wanted to show you this
you guys know rick owens right
designer
yeah yeah
okay i'm gonna put don't show this i'll
show her the i'll show her the unedited
one and then i'll put up the edited one
yeah there's a d there's a dick okay is
that okay
it's high fashion it's not like it's
just it's a fashion dick
as long as it's fashionable yeah it's a
fashion dick i don't i think it'd be
okay
so where's the dick one though i'm dick
tip
i don't believe we had that one in the
dock but i could send you that dick real
quick give me one sec
yeah send me that dick please
yeah so he did a fashion collection
where
the
highlight the main focus was
the dick
and i've never seen anything like it and
i'm curious what you think
uh ela what did you think about this
collection as a fashionista
i um like
laughed out loud
when i saw the picture which i don't
normally do like
it was a reaction don't show this okay
uh ian
you ready to not show it
yeah so here's this this beautiful piece
what do you
think god
[ __ ] gnarly
thoughts
i thought that was like
that's not a malfunction that's
intentional no i didn't think that it
was a malfunction i thought it was like
a pouch
[Music]
i think it might have been very cold in
that room
and then it it kind of looked just like
a like underwear
and then i was like oh my god that's a
ball sack and then i was like oh my god
yeah so let me show you guys the edited
version so you guys know what we're
talking about oh my god this is the one
that's safe for youtube
uh of course
wait
oh my god it's called
dick owens good lord okay let's be
confident no that one doesn't have dick
in it but this one here this is what
pokey saw with how we of course crazy
keeping it clean no but i feel like if i
was a viewer at home and i saw that i
would imagine
oh behind that is just a pee pee
but it's not it is like ninety percent
it's like it's thick and bald and it's a
lot of balls
perfectly
i don't know yeah
yeah he doesn't fit very well but his
balls are normal size
so it's a lot of balls
to be honest i didn't really i didn't
want to comment too much on it because i
just don't know enough about this well
there's a lot to know you're right and
that's fair right yeah
i think that as a fashion piece though
it's cool just i would wear it with
pants oh no dick out dude actually and
that was just underwear that would be
cool
rick's like listen it's a cool top
i heard normally in an interview i will
not sell this to anyone unless they're
dick out in it
wow dick out or nothing
very intentional with his art oh you
know what why don't we tweet it so if
people that want to see they can go
they can go enjoy this high fashion
situation lots of balls very little dick
can you tweet that out totally fine yeah
yeah you could tweet anything you could
tweet
prolapsed anus which we have
or you could post it on tick tock
exactly so you're maybe tweet first
the censored one and then reply with the
real one wait do you guys have it
because i've never seen it i've never
heard you talk about it
uh do we have it oh do we have it three
million people have seen it and not me
uh do we have it do you have it it's
right here are you ready yes all right
well hold on first first um post the cut
the rick dick i can't believe i come
from the h3 podcast and i'm just seeing
genitalia left and right wait you see
dick wait to see this butthole
dick balls and butthole oh my
what a treat and we know how to treat
our guests too
and water what more could i need love
you got the dick
yeah i got it thanks buddy all right so
guys yeah when you post it put it with
the thing where you have to yeah right
you don't have to write okay
that's fashion
it's better if people just look at it
they're like why'd they tweet this
picture of this guy oh wait you yeah you
can't take nothing you see uh there's
gonna be a no blur i think oh god you
can't do it just please put it okay it's
fine it's just black i hope you have the
whole video if possible
if you don't let me ask you this are
balls more offensive than dick or less
i think less
is less
interesting yeah
because i feel like people make a lot of
gags about
balls is that a weird
sentence you know
like tea bagging in games or i don't
know people joke about that part okay
let me tell you more than that well let
me ask let me rephrase this if you were
at a beach
and a dude was walking around with a
slit and his balls were out just his
balls
dick concealed
or assume he's just trying to get some
vitamin d in that area as i've heard is
just so helpful for men's health right
that's interesting or or a guy who just
had his head
like the balls like someone just said it
balls are like funny i think that's what
i read a comment and i i
think that we know they're kind of like
it would be more funny i feel then like
i'm assaulted right right okay
you know okay so there you have it this
is god's exclamation point
i think yeah we can do a poll but i
think you guys are kind of spot on i
think you guys know better than me
about what's scary the other day i was
on a walk on a hot girl walk i don't
know if you guys have heard of those but
i was walking outside
um
in like a
west hollywood-ish
in like a well-known area
anyways i walked by and there's this
very very fancy white car don't know
what it's called and a guy who had
stepped out and was just pissing on the
pole beside his fancy ass car with two
girls in the car
i was like is that normal like he looked
he was for sure rich he's probably drunk
people just get up and piss on the side
of streets i know i think so i don't
think that's normal
yeah i don't
think even i think even the homeless
have more dignity than that no for real
i was like you're clearly not homeless
bro you're driving like a lambo and
you're pissing your balls
yeah but you saw it bothered me the most
because like he could see that i was
walking towards him oh and i had to stop
and just go on the other side
cause he wouldn't even stop he was he
was you know just doing this looking
back at me like yeah i'm pissing that's
correct okay sir
wait what is this pull
that's a bad i'm loading shaft what
okay so
basically it's closer than i thought
what are we talking about
it's kind of a bad pull uh of course it
is
it is actually this time dan wrote um
what's more insulting to your
eyes balls or shaft and why is shaft
specifically i'm talking about the whole
penis including the head um
we're just looking at the shaft well
maybe they're looking for a word that i
just was using shaft to kind of sum up
you know the whole thing but the piece
just just distinguish it i don't know
the shaft and head all right what is the
shaft what are the confusions let's go
again
i thought
the rod human dev class let's go what's
the question what's the question you've
got you've got the shaft okay and on top
you've got
the mushroom gotcha so it is a bad pull
you're talking about not the whole well
how do you how do you sum up penis
but okay
but it seems that most people are
offended by when you say penis you
usually think of it as a unit with the
balls that's why i was trying to
distinguish no
but we yeah we said
okay so is the the question was there an
issue with the question wait i have an
interesting uh comment from olivia
the state of the dick matters more i
think so so you're saying an erection
would be scary that's weird of course
like the scarier that's like right
but i think i would
like yeah the sight of balls i feel like
maybe is a little more than like a
a not excited
really
peace you know
does that make sense really i don't know
personal preference i guess but
just in this situation you're walking
down the street the dude has a slit in
his pants and his balls are out
everything else concealed i think also
you have to consider if someone's
balls are out it could be an accident no
this isn't in this case it's not but as
an observer you have no way to know
whereas if the willy wonka is out it's
for sure intentionally
i'm trying to think a word because you
know
there is there is certain situations
where guys if they were like really high
athletic shorts the ball the balls can
actually my popular
male streamer friend was telling me that
occurred to him not too long ago
so that's why i'm like oh it could be an
accident
and that's what i'd assume if i ever
unfortunately came across such a sight
well there it is gentlemen do not walk
around with your wrecked uh penis out
that is a no go
right here right now guys put that
soaked through put those away
break a new ground here yeah you didn't
know that already
this is educational podcast
okay so are you ready to see the
prolapse
okay so camera on uh pokey you ready for
this oh it was oh oh my god okay okay so
this is a big moment you haven't seen it
all right i'm pulling it up now
howie mendel ladies and gentlemen
oh god
we need audio dude
we need audio audio audio
over this happen
does somebody know is this covid related
and if it is
what do we do about it
when my friend neil bent over this
happened
does somebody know is this covid related
and if it is what do we do about it
my friend neil
that man howie mandel posted a severely
prolapsed anus to tick-tock thoughts i'm
gonna be honest when i heard you talk
about a prolapsed ant you know i was
like
oh like it's a little open or something
like that his guts are pouring out yeah
yeah yeah yeah between his it looks like
baron if anyone's played league
pull up a picture of baron yeah let me
pull that up yeah no his and he's
literally his intestines his large and
says is prolapsed out of his [ __ ] i
didn't know that was humanly possible
yeah so this is a question i ask people
is this a prolapse of of uh
intentional prolapse or accidental
prolapse
if that's accidental that is so
concerning and if it's intentional it's
still very concerning
why is the person wearing something very
playful and we have a picture of it
that's what makes me think that it is no
no actually intentionally we need to
look into this a little bit further
there's
i have something my friend neil i have
something when my friend neil bent over
this happened why is there a hole around
the bottle yeah so i think they were
doing some kind of role playing where
they're like
because i don't think you can actually
prolapse this bat he's wearing like that
but no way it would like pop out of your
shorts right like they must have cut
that whole intentionally yeah i think so
yeah they cut the hole out i think this
is a prolapse of pleasure and and and
god bless him you know there's a lot you
can do with that thing god bless him but
don't post it on people
well that's i don't i would like to know
more i'm trying to get a hold of howie
he won't talk to me i want to know how
he became in possession of this uh
prolapse you know whenever you put this
on the screen you know that feeling you
get where you've got you're driving and
you want to just jerk the wheel right
sometimes like what would happen don't
[ __ ] right into the wall there's a
button right next to when you just put
it on the screen
in your career right now you mean you
mean like when you wanted when you like
oh i could just uh have a full head-on
collision with the car on the other side
yeah like
the button is right there that would
just put it on the screen yeah
let's not even joke i really i need to
ask
yeah
what kind of homies do you have to just
be sending you their prolapsed anus the
best kinds
the closest of homies only they're for
sure kissing goodness for sure
for sure yeah okay so that's so there
you have it i mean it is it's as
horrific as you imagined or more way
more
way about ten times worse than i
thought this is so great maybe i'm a
text howard right now and i'm saying
listen just tell me where you got the
photo from and i'll stop bothering you
he told you from his friend
his friend neil
tell me
how you got the he must hate my guts how
i always talk about it
just tell me how you got the photo
that's it i feel like now i see it in
everything too like if i see a shape
[Music]
please show them baron
oh [ __ ] wait there's another one
that is so crazy i can't show it
and i sent it to howie that's how i got
uh just reminded myself
what do you mean another wait hold on
pull this up i got to show you this
pokey this is insane and then cam maybe
you can make an edit wait this is worse
dude it's not worse but it's as bad
well that up where did this come from
i saw it on reddit and i sent it to
howie
and he said now we're just going to look
is it the car one yeah yeah yeah okay
i've managed to avoid seeing
unfortunately what is the show turning
in
wait he commented on it okay you're
gonna love this
he said
he said best one yet you post it
and then and then he said about her she
should be on america's got talent that
talent looks
uh wait don't
no he's making jokes he's got more
talent than problem
pull it up
i sent it in the chat it's in the
discord it's not a private conversation
it's all fun and games oh my god okay
all right you off
no head-on collisions please you're
stressing me out audible
from the cast and crew
this one is worse i'm not looking at it
this one's worse you think this is yeah
oh yes i've never seen this one no i
like this one better okay you ready for
this pokemon worry me i'm not gonna no
no what are you talking about you have
to look you have to engage into the
abyss
you have to gaze into the abyss
um sam sent it in the chat and i read it
at the nail salon read it i read the
message watched the crazy video at the
nail salon and
it was a good experience if i'll be
honest like with you i thought it was
hilarious how that's a big vouch howie
like that i will say and cam can you
make an edited version we can show the
people i'm on it right now thank you cam
all right eli you gotta look you gotta
do this for me i mean i'll try it don't
look away okay you have to gaze into the
beast they want you to tweet it the bees
what are you saying
himself sauron man
you have to know what is on this planet
yeah we'll tweet it we'll tweet it as
well
the uncensored okay elon and pokey this
is for you guys
when my friend neil bent over this
happened does somebody know is this
[Applause]
what the [ __ ]
but like on the side of the freeway
this was that a man or a woman it was a
woman woman yeah it was a woman that
means that they couldn't control it they
had to stop and just do it in the
freeway no she's putting on a show i
think no yeah i think it's a show
wait what is it for who
for everyone else on the freeway
tweet the video
a willful you're trying to get all your
followers to unfollow you i'm gonna i'm
gonna reply with the video to the other
tweet okay okay perfect yeah the people
gotta see this one uh it's up right now
both of them are up uh okay it's up on
the twitter as a reply to the original
okay i'm gonna watch it again you guys
uh and take it off i just want to
analyze this if i could please i'll
describe it as good i can for the people
at home
so
when my friends a woman bent over
they're all stuck in traffic
are you serious david you got a cube
from a little prolapse
come on bro
nice [ __ ] look like majin buu that was
disgusting oh
you know he regenerates that's what it
looked like oh my god isn't that what
you said i look like no no everything
looked like the same tbz character i'm
like
audibly describe it in any way just
imagine someone bending over
and you see their butthole but then you
see their guts like coming out of it
right and back in the sense of
breathing yeah it's sort of that does
not but it's the situation that makes it
more bizarre she's on the side
of traffic of a heavily trafficked road
wait wait
i'm so
close for some reason the the guts just
low-key look like baron what can i say
yeah because they're like red and purple
i'm scared to bring it up yeah i don't
want to press the wrong button here okay
wait let me thank you so much for that
god god bless you
um oh can you to show an image where you
can see all the traffic because that
one's close up i want people to
understand
yes so she's bent over during heavily
trafficked someone in a truck is filming
her as he drives by her
and she's flexing her [ __ ]
but no like she's flexing her guts
coming out of her she's pushing like her
whole intestines out of her [ __ ] and
then sucking it back in terrific it
sounds like a bad bad anime you know
oh my
some people look for this guy someone in
the comments said her hazards were on
that's what's up
yeah i'm gonna watch it if you guys
don't see it's five i'm gonna watch it
by myself here let me know when it's
done it seems like everybody agrees it's
way worse
does somebody know is this covid related
and if it is what what do we do about it
oh my god it looks like a see an enemy
her [ __ ] doesn't it when it's fully
out did you guys originally see this
posted onto the subreddit
like on our subreddit no i saw it on a
subreddit called crazy [ __ ] videos
and what was so great is that it already
had the howie
meme on it
here here's the setting just so you guys
can tell
uh she's bent over here it's all safe
for you thank you but she's so
who's the show for for herself for her
own pleasure is somebody what's
happening no it's it's gorilla theater
you think
[Laughter]
you guys really think that well she's
literally like
doing she's like there's choreography to
it oh maybe they were filming this
somebody driving by or oh maybe there's
someone else there they wanted to go
viral
like maybe they're filming it for um how
do i say this inappropriate audiences
they're doing adult audiences oh so she
says i'm sure someone's into not just
the the baron coming out but also like
the uh is it like exhibitionist stuff is
that what it's called bro this is yes so
maybe that combination you know
she was like hey i'm about to make a
buck 50 right now high brow art you know
what happens that would cause this
like i'm just wondering if this could
not be like uncontrolled you guys all no
no that she controls i think i think
with a lot of practice i know what
you're saying
with a lot of this is not an accident no
it's not an accident that's a skill
that's a woman with skill and experience
i feel like i'm the extent
of it
like if if if prolapse were to occur on
accident it wouldn't be to this extent
you know what i mean
what was the n and that out
yeah you know
that's crazy bro
so there you go that one's for you i
sent that to howie he loved it
ladies and gentlemen did he wow yeah he
loved it i thought it was great
he was like hey yo that's me
oh yeah um people of culture is what we
call those people when you
what you were trying to say that maybe
it's for men of course
yeah a man of color kind of culture of a
very specific culture i like people
because maybe it's women true people of
a certain
interest group
overlapping with another interest group
so there that is
uh we did that the intersection of kinks
hey let me ask you this
since we're on the topic of gross [ __ ]
did you say did you see how well uh uh
steve will do it about how he jerks off
his dog oh my god i saw you talking
about it and i was like who is this why
is he talking about
doing things to his dog and then doing
things to his friend's daughter i was so
confused i kind of turned my brain off
you know oh yeah so you've seen it
i haven't seen it i saw you talk about
it but do you want to give me context
you i'll just open it
sure
it's great
so many years honestly i missed my
ex-girlfriend's dog i'm just hitting you
with all the
with all the best i miss my
ex-girlfriend's dog yeah not like not
like steve does fox
i miss i swear i really miss that's dude
that's the thing oh dude when we broke
up we broke it for eight months or is it
how how i started telling her i started
messaging donald trump i'm sure like
nothing can't miss her daughter
sorry yeah
um
he's
recently he's been like you come home
and there's just come everywhere what
are you talking about i come over the
couches
and but you see it you see the [ __ ]
yeah usually comes stains and his dick
is like
all big and throbbing so like it sucks
but like
this is like kind of crazy i'm saying
this but
one
i'm the cool dad now okay and i'm the
favorite you're the favorite of the
queen and two
you can control where the [ __ ] goes
what are you talking about
so i get ivs all the time yeah yeah i
know you know they wear gloves yes so
lately i've been just like groceries ago
you put on the glove and you said donald
he's going on his stomach or like
something right here or like you go cow
style cow
styles
better for catching and then you go and
usually just play like uh like uh like i
like cartoon like disney like family
friendly and [ __ ] uh and he's
has been uh i've been just like jerking
off donnie jerking your dog off i swear
wait wait wait wait wait hold on so
you're telling me right now that you've
been jerking your dog off and now so he
doesn't cool dad
it might sound crazy but it's my
business
i did listen to you
i i just missed i guess the first part
yeah is this for help purposes then
he does it because he wants to be a
homie he wants to be a good homie to his
dog no no no no no no no no he says his
dog doesn't have hands so i gotta beat
him off oh yeah for starters why is your
dog cool done
um you know doing things everywhere i
feel like that's an abnormal behavior
which leads me to think maybe this is an
issue his dog has and then his vet told
him to but if your vet didn't tell you
to
don't do it no no no no this was not
veterinarian are you sure bro listen to
this yeah yeah
he just says like can you imagine if you
couldn't do it to yourself so he's like
he thinks he's helping the dog bro is he
crazy this is the love of the game guys
myself and it's more of just a
it's more of a um a little workout but
the thing is like dude i'm the cool dad
because imagine if you couldn't jerk off
and like i was like what the [ __ ] i do
he comes by like [ __ ] a pillow
you know that's his normal that's his
normal move do yeah but you know imagine
you're trying to come back like [ __ ]
a pillow like it's probably like hard
that's not it's probably not the best
but then imagine you i don't have a dog
but that's not normal right yeah no dude
no
well disturbing
joe budden says he fingers his female
dog and i'm sorry about that
you guys need to stop talking about your
pets online okay in any i can't believe
people have to say this in any sexual
capacity whatsoever do not talk about
your pets
look i thought we learned from i'm very
brave very brave of you
come on now
[Applause]
sometimes when shredder is sitting next
to me and it's late at night
i like to
[Music]
you know
don't do it don't do it no no
ladies wait do you know what this
reminds me of which i hate that i'm
saying this
has any does anyone know such deep
internet lore
that
there used to be this girl who had an
entire youtube channel
dedicated yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's the best she made a video about
like the top eight reasons that you
should be with your dog instead of a
human partner
yeah was there any compelling reasons on
that one
couldn't tell you i couldn't tell you
probably all the compelling it just blew
my mind one that someone made this and
two that it was a video that was allowed
to flourish
upon a platform you know what number one
was
loyalty
if you ain't got loyalty what do you got
back
probably good d too bro crazy
yeah here's joe budden saying fingers is
[ __ ] funny i thought this is so funny
i'm so sorry i thought you said joe
biden
i figured my dog man got that
[Music]
when she's in heat i just slip a finger
right in there man
oh no it's probably best i don't know
jail
jail time for you sir here's joe budden
okay he's my guy right i'm sorry it's a
girl
we're just using slurs don't worry about
it
why do i always want to make the dog
feel good by playing with their [ __ ]
privates
i know that he's not a real animal uh
lover because i don't play with my pets
anybody with a pet you come on you did a
little something down there man
by the way steve will do it's like yup
preacher brother
bro it's not even his dog
you know what i find really really funny
cool dad
people just start talking so much on the
internet they don't even realize when
they're saying [ __ ] up [ __ ] yeah
because they don't even know that it's
[ __ ] up and it really it gives you
such insight into them as a human being
wow
there's this whole zoophile thing that's
going on and i love it could that not be
considered some form of like sexual
abuse to an animal we debated that we
were like it should
what steve will do it is doing to his
dog is this illegal or not i can't
decide i i don't know we need to
dude we've got can we call emp can we
get pnp on the line by the way do you
guys like bathroom breaks i kind of
really need to beautiful
yo can we seriously get p and p on the
line i want to know you can try
the first rule of fingering your dog is
not to ever admit it god damn it
finger your dog and run
how did we always talk to him um i'm
trying to remember who has oh [ __ ] i
asked howie just tell me how you got the
photo and he said i just used a mirror
oh my god this guy what are we doing i
can't i can't with howie he's the
greatest
ow
what a [ __ ] legend dude i can't holly
mandel ladies and gentlemen a real one i
told you he's funny he's the realest one
yeah when he's not like the thing is he
just play it so clean when he's on
camera he's become very family friendly
but
under under the veneer of america's got
talent there's a uh very dirty comic by
the way the man won't shake a hand but
he'll show you an [ __ ]
we did some snooping if you go to howie
mandel he follows this guy named neil so
this may be the
and it's the only spelling of neil so
now
so that neil shawn is the guitarist for
journey the band show oh he took me on a
journey all right
a journey to the eye of the wait wait
could that be what the wheel in the sky
means
the prologue oh my lord
with a prolapse in the sky
well that's that's not yeah but so neil
we've seen your anus bro don't stop
believing neil
get well soon you can get over kobe dude
[Laughter]
is this cover related howie oh neil must
have had covet at the same time so is is
was that covid related we have to figure
it out
any way you want it neil
that's the way you we need to get in
touch we'll get in touch i just love the
way you need it
by the way someone reaching out to pnp
i i'm trying
i'm trying to figure out where we're in
contact with him and i can text him on
the um wasn't it tick tock dms was it
just tick tock or did we get
let me message him on tik tok because
this was actually important let's go i'm
going to message him and say we have an
important and urgent legal question for
you
um pnp where are you my boy
p
and p here he is
so uh how he responded he looked to
ethan he did yeah
do you want to share it just now he said
i said how did you get the picture and
he said i took it in the mirror
what a legend nobody has a funny guy
okay so i said we have an urgent yeah
i'm just searching through my email i
guess what i didn't set it up through
email olivia did you reach out to him
perhaps
no i was at school when you guys had him
yeah oh you missed that okay
[Music]
pokey brought these
stroop waffles oh wait those are
delicious you guys get this
they hit hard
so good
hook it up dan
it's actually one of my favorite uh
dan's just grabbing one for himself
have one
no no oh cam shut up
get out
get back in your cell cam
you ask for too damn much
what the [ __ ] through the wall
you're just falling i was trying to hold
it up no just feed me i don't need holy
[ __ ] your little hands are so cute
though
[Laughter]
yum yum
wow
they have those in amsterdam or another
oh you guys want to look at ela's super
cute instagram photo i do
yeah i love that post
so you got a notification on your iphone
or
i don't know what it was i was looking
at like google photos i think
and sometimes it does this like
highlights
that they put together
so it said from seven years ago so i was
kind of curious i usually never click on
it but
it was like this week seven years ago
yeah apparently we moved to new york
seven years ago
here i am getting off the airplane in
new york and it was also right after
moving from israel to america in general
wow i think we were just maybe a couple
months in l.a and then we decided to go
to new york so this was like all of our
belongings we had to take everything
with us my most precious and expensive
belonging was my computer which i had to
put in a [ __ ] box and store on the
airplane
when i got it out it was totally
destroyed
it was like the motherboard was torn out
the car the
crap
yeah because i could not afford to buy a
new one
so there was that
this is us leaving or arriving this is
us arriving in new york i think right i
think
and you guys were there for only a year
right yeah one year just one year
this is the apartment how we got it like
this is how we got it i think people
left some trash in there we had to empty
it was three stories
no no elevator
we we bought like chairs we had to carry
it up ourselves everything was such
sounds like new york i think yeah
and this was our first setup oh yeah
there's a lot of good videos shot right
yeah i recognize the fireplace me too
yeah this was a very creative
space for us we did a lot of good stuff
there
and this is me on the airplane
so there it is uh ela cline a cute post
by uh
beautiful
of uh cute posts
no i wanted to ask what are the comments
on that video like oh nobody's talking
about it
it's so weird confusing
i want to see i'm the only person on the
internet talking about this he just just
came out by the way it gets even worse
you said that
he talks about how he scoops the calm
out and [ __ ] and like he does it because
he goes yo imagine let me just finish
that's the part that i i had to leave a
comment i was like no
i couldn't hear it it's just 30 more
seconds i'll play for you and then i'm
gonna scroll down you bro but i think
like there's plenty of reasons i gotta
control where the [ __ ] goes okay and i
feel like he likes me better than he
likes me way better than selena now
because i'm the cool dad dude i'll be
honest i didn't see this conversation
going that way but i was i kind of like
crazy i kind of respect it
dude if you couldn't jerk off i'm trying
to put myself in that position and it's
like donnie can't go to the rub and tug
no yeah he can't there's no dog hookers
damn they're also dogs
um they can't like give
consent per se
it's just weird it ain't right they're
an animal but like unless absolutely
necessary like you i feel like you just
we don't as humans know what's going on
in their head like
sure they can be in heat they can
whatever that doesn't mean they want you
as their owner
to do that oh but he's the cool dad now
so
do you think he smells his fingers after
he finished or not all right okay too
far connie i was just curious because
he's in there pretty deep no
that's weird maybe just a little taste
don't ah
well he's
ending the whole show huh
that bad okay sorry guys i love that his
name is stiff we'll do it yeah zach had
a great one
he says steve will jerk it yeah
um so so i'll continue i'll continue
like bro you just got your mom and dad
mom's not cool you don't have a girl you
don't have girl dogs to [ __ ] no girl but
frenchies you can't [ __ ] what
fact-checked me here they're [ __ ]
[ __ ] bag losers they're known for uh
crypto gambling steak and also spread
like not caring about kovid basically
yeah they're the worst and just being i
used to be
yeah
they're the worst i used to be such a
drake fan girl drake is [ __ ] sad ever
since
so you have a problem showing your true
colors i hate drake
as the canadian we're disowning you
right
we'll keep the music though wow
well this is interesting because
obviously you're on twitch and i have a
big problem with the stick thing i talk
about all the time bigger problems okay
tell me about it tell me your thoughts
about it
when you did uh it was like that group
call or whatever i was like get me in
bro because i
was so
listen i wish i could just speak to
someone who does like crypto gambling
and explain to them like
one we could are you dumb
if no then you must be able to
understand that whatever money this
company is giving you it's because they
are profiting more
from whatever marketing and
advertisement that you are doing and
their profits are your viewers losses
yeah therefore your profits are your
viewers losses well it's even more
direct than that because a lot of these
guys had referral codes they were
getting not to mention that it could be
addicting
exactly and it can ruin lives right but
even just
understanding the business marketing
behind it
how can you feel good about taking money
from people
like that
it might be that like guys like xqc and
trainwreck are actually just addicts and
so they're not really thinking straight
about it aiden rosh is a piece of [ __ ] i
don't think that
is hard to explain
uh yeah i considered that angle too but
and i i think i gave them a bit of
leeway for walks i was like oh like they
must be addicted as well but if that's
the case i think they kind of have a
responsibility as people who are in such
positions of privilege
power and influence seek treatment if
you are addicted
don't use that as a reason to just
spread it around yeah
well love says that xqc says that he
recently lost four million off of the
stream he said yeah that was a while ago
but he did say that he's gambling off
you know
when they say stuff like that i think in
their minds it's you know they're trying
to say guys look i'm a real one i'm
losing a lot hear me out right i'm a
real one what i hear is [ __ ] you have
four million to throw away like that
you must be making eight not at least
yeah you're right no that's true yeah
like has to blows my mind it really it
really pisses me off all in all though i
just hope twitch takes action because
i i cannot trust individual content
creators too that's what i wonder like
for you being on this platform
it's gotta suck that this is what's the
biggest thing right now right like slot
machines yeah and drake like the big
star is coming over and then this is
what they're all doing
luckily in terms of traction i feel like
the the gambling section of twitch is
kind of like a section to the side if i
saw it like plastered everywhere and i
heard everybody talking about it and
actively watching i would be so mad i'm
still mad
but at least it's not like popular on
twitch it's just like a part of twitch
that i wish wasn't to be frank i think
it's good you speak out about it because
a lot of the people
wait somebody said my twitter's been
hacked no they're asking them
and then under it is the new prolapse
here's the tweet wait let me read some
of the comments under the new prolapse
the freeway prolapse
i need my i need to mine my business
sometimes i collect the show i can't
follow simple orders is this covert
related she's giving them a show
respectfully it's time to stomp ow
had enough internet for the day yeah
respectfully i think it's good you speak
out about the gambling stuff because
the people who are doing gambling are
actually
beloved and very influential people like
xqc is probably he's probably the
biggest streamer on the platform so i
actually think he's kind of the
exception to the role i think most other
people that do gambling and train wreck
is big also train wrecks
his viewership numbers are big
but i think because he does so much
gambling he's really really in like one
category right now okay
so i wouldn't say
he's like
similar to xqc per se yes but it's just
it strikes me as also actually xqc gets
away with the
um
yeah you think there's a double standard
there
um
no i think he's just really really
popular and sometimes when you have so
much not just popularity but he streams
a lot and he does make a lot of really
good content and he has a really really
close connection with his viewership his
massive viewership
so i think because of that a lot of
people have a lot of love for him and
this thing
like it kind of taints his name per se
but because there's still so much else
it can't like ruin it because he's also
known for so many other like good things
love you're a fan how much of his
content is gambling versus gaming
yeah not a crazy amount i guess
maybe a couple a week two maybe yeah but
also understand he does like 12 plus
hour streams regularly so that's why if
he only got on stream and only did
gambling there would be a lot more to
say
yeah he streamed 277 hours uh this month
bro what how many hours are there in a
month
for real
we're talking like
70
yeah yeah he's crazy
um
yeah train wrecks
actually i i see him sometimes kind of
um
like rant on twitter about this stuff
and also about like
why people don't recognize him as much
as a larger streamer like with his
numbers
but i think what he fails to understand
is that it's because he's in a category
that is kind of hidden
like if someone is big within gambling
a 90 of twitch viewers like don't watch
gambling that's why whereas if he but
why is he even complaining it's like bro
you play slots what recognition do you
want you play slots yeah he's like i
stream this much and i have this
viewership and no one's talking about me
but if you did that across the popular
platforms everybody would be talking
about you but you do that in a in a
category that people don't talk about
that much i play smart so [ __ ] hard
like hey yo this person just won a
million dollar like you know
yo i play slot so [ __ ] hard bro why
nobody recognize me
um
he said on our stream he they pay him
two million dollars
a month
for the gambling i'm sure that's gone up
to be honest yeah it's probably more but
if you look at twitch right now you can
see the is this the most popular
well
is that twitch right now right now yeah
right now yeah
well that's way bigger than i would
expect every time i go it's a lot like
if you go to twitch right now
yeah let's go see it really does blow me
away
um
let's see
um categories you would like or [ __ ] how
do you click the word categories
do you fall on there
um i do
just chatting a lot of gaming a lot of
valorant that's my primary game i've
been playing played up recently i've
played among us i've played fortnite in
the past minecraft gta everything really
let's sort by uh view count so it's
right here you're right it's not not at
the top but it's like no 1080 000 is way
more than i expected can you click it
sure
it's because russian stein is live
oh
i've literally i've never even looked at
the category
yeah it's all slot machines too which is
like the most [ __ ] up form of gambling
and it's all steak pretty incredible and
the least interesting to watch too is
what yeah how is that interesting like
at least like poker there's like
strategy going on and like there's a
game to it it's a slot machine there's
like nothing happening it's easiest for
kids to understand i guess
interesting interesting i've had so many
people even mods
that i have reach out to me and say like
thank you for speaking out against this
because like i know someone in my family
who's addicted and it has just ruined
our entire family like the impact that
this can have people don't really see at
all they say gambling it's the deadliest
addiction actually it results in the
most unaliving of any addiction it's it
is horrible yeah it's horrible
it's very very very very destructive i
mean love here we used to
love he tells us about how he got sucked
into gambling with from cs go yeah
gambling back back in the day because
he's a young man
you started gambling at what age love
14 probably yeah um and i gotta say ever
since this twitch stream has been been
becoming bigger because i watch xqc a
lot and that [ __ ] makes my gambling
addiction tingle
[Music]
it's really bad makes you want to does
it make you want to play sloths or
something else i mean i i i'm pretty i i
can keep myself from doing it but i i
sometimes i'm like should i should i do
it should i do it i just got my paycheck
i just got my paycheck should i ask you
though
i'm just curious to prod into the
emotion a little bit is it because
you're you have a dream of winning a lot
of money or you just like the idea or
what is it
i don't know it's just like it's
something i can't it's definitely not
the money that was that was it before
when i did it when i was younger i
wanted money
nowadays it's something way less uh
contrasty or whatever it's so called
yeah can't even
less concrete it's more yeah less
concrete yeah it's more of a okay that
is interesting wow
yeah apparently somebody said
that um
train wreck lost
16 million dollars
is that right that's what the message
said train like lost 800 bitcoin last
stream which is 16 million in one stream
but i just wonder like when they say
those kind of statements how real is it
like is that money that was just given
frame to play with and then he lost it
because 100
so then it's like
who cares you know what i mean actually
yeah they've probably never deposited
money
exactly so like yeah yeah you lost 20
million like who cares that's all money
they put in your bank to play with yeah
because it's part of the sponsorship
they have a vested interest in you keep
playing viewers don't be fooled when
they say stuff like that they want to
act like oh i'm i'm detracting my
audience from doing this you're actually
just flexing the fact that you can
gamble with millions and millions of
dollars like that's not normal let me
ask you just you have that much money go
go do something go promote something
else man you do not need gambling money
let me ask you this because we were
looking at train train wreck recently
and he gets into this thing was like do
not gamble guys you will lose everything
it's going to ruin your life gambling
it's horrible don't do it
you really believe that you wouldn't
promote it yeah it's that simple to me
yeah
interesting there's so many like
gimmicks and like marketing stuff people
if you don't want people to gamble don't
promote it
he goes he goes i like gambling it's fun
it's my past time but you guys don't
ever gamble if it's your past time you
don't need to promote it especially if
you know like if you know your behavior
as a streamer as a content creator as an
influencer as a whatever a person in the
public eye
you have to understand your behavior
influences what other people want to do
if that's the case well they know that
they don't get okay
they're paying them
so clearly that
there you go there it is you know you
heard it here from uh
the pokemon's mouth
actually like uh i saw that you talked
in your video about how it's kind of
hard for you to talk about but you
wanted to maybe get into other things
other than gaming yeah
what is
what do you
think about anything specific or is it
just you kind of feeling like over it
yeah okay so i've been streaming since i
was like 17.
and every two years or so i kind of just
hit a roadblock where i'm like i i need
to disappear for a little bit and just
kind of touch grass and touch face with
myself
but this time when i took a break i came
back feeling like
i i don't want to lead my life in the
exact same way that i used to especially
in regards to streaming just because
it's not as creatively fulfilling for me
now as it once was like i want to do it
two three times a week not six times a
week thinking about it all the time
keeping up with trends because that's
what top streamers do you have to always
know what's going on and honestly you
have to work your schedule around
streaming schedule because certain
things pop off
like kind of unannounced certain things
happen for very specific periods of time
and you have to make sure that you're
around for those times and like i
i just want to start exploring other
avenues especially vlogging especially
like instagram tick tock just posting
more content on those platforms making
um like pre-produced content reels all
those things really anything aside from
yeah i mean just streaming and gaming we
understand that obviously that's why we
did the podcast yeah like you you can
only do the same thing for so long
exactly that's not a it's not a disc to
anyone who does that obviously it's like
you know but if you evolve you've got to
change that's human nature you know it
was really hard because we were so stuck
in the like reaction videos and i think
you guys kind of tried to juggle
initially and then at one point you were
like we're just we're just gonna
and probably like it works way better
with your lifestyle especially as
parents business owners yeah yeah i
completely that was part of like why we
needed to to change too because you grow
up you figure
wait it's going to be healthy for me to
be able to take the weekend off like you
know simple things that you just kind of
like neglect i know
yeah it's very
it's it's kind of an all-consuming
lifestyle
the truth is if you want longevity you
have to be aware of the signals that
you're getting from yourself and you
need to
change
or you're gonna [ __ ] just burn out
you're gonna end up jerking off your dog
and then talking about it on a podcast
bad [ __ ] happens you know what i mean
i'm pregnanting like it's not honestly
like i'm trying to give them the benefit
of the doubt of like maybe that was a
joke no
no
they talked about it for so much it was
very very there's no like humor in it i
don't know
when i see stuff like that also it makes
me realize like wow there are so many
pockets of the internet
right
there's half a million people that think
this is cool okay
a little scary
over here
dan just gave me a fan this fan is so
quiet
oh
you guys want a fan
we got him we there's one blowing up my
i've attached it to the scorpion chair
here i don't know i love the setup so
cool this curve yeah
it looks cooler than it is is this like
a load a low noise fan
yeah they're just really real quiet i
wouldn't say low noise but
yeah it's definitely quieter than the ac
which we have running and i'm sure it
can be heard on the mic so you know it
is so [ __ ] hot right it's a fast day
it's i don't know what happened today
spicy usually they see like you can feel
it more i guess it's just that hot
i'm getting an excessive
nice that thing is nice
bless your soul
we got fans for everybody
strider he's
helping mine doesn't pick up mine
i'm listening
ah that's nice
no it's
people are asking you have no ac we do
there's two you do building they're both
on it's just that hot
the insulation the insulation is [ __ ]
non-existent
yeah you're always gonna sweat yeah
usually it's fine usually it's great in
here also shout out to the crew
can someone play the applause button
thank you
thank you i mean there's literally no
speculation like the roof is open to the
elements in so many spots the elephants
look like i mean i could see the outside
right there
in my head a little bit a little bit
it's maybelline
i definitely hear it on your mic ela
oh you're trying to be a buzz kill yeah
this is way too good i feel like oh
that's so it shouldn't be that
comfortable yes so
um
yeah i think just take your time and do
what feels right but it's good yeah it's
good you took a month off yeah i just
needed to tell people like hey
don't expect full-time streamer hours
for me anymore
do you have any idea kind of like
in terms of like moving towards
something aggressively in a big way
like for us was the podcast like we had
an idea a lot of times we're just kind
of wandering around
wondering what are we going to do and
then
we'll get struck with a really good idea
that sticks with us like and so we'll go
after that do you feel like you have
something like that or not yeah i think
for me right now what i am most excited
by
is
the idea of some sort of combination
between like
vlogs and like sit down talking about
topics kind of thing yeah especially
seeing such good reception to my most
recent video i'm like
yeah y'all want to hear some more [ __ ] i
got some more [ __ ] to say
yeah yeah and i find it's
as someone who is used to like
four to eight hour form content
shortening something and kind of just
like
jotting down notes and saying it for
like a five to ten minute video feels so
good yeah that's pretty really so good
yeah yeah those are the two things i'm
yeah hoping i can do something it was so
hard for us to go the opposite way from
that's all the people saw to then seeing
like the unedited and i find that
interesting too because it's like
i think every now and then and i've seen
videos of youtubers who do what i want
to do and they're like guys i'm kind of
over this and i think it's just like
human nature yeah and different things
fit with your lifestyle different times
so
go with what works you know yeah
great yeah i think you're doing the
right thing so just keep doing it
excited and uh and doing more stuff like
this yeah
way more time to be like i'll just
dedicate this day to a podcast and like
normally
if this was me two years ago i'd be like
okay after this stream i need to go on
my stream right that's what we do with
every thursday yeah and his ass is
always like out the door yeah i don't
know but he loves it he's like a beast i
don't know so hard yeah yeah and when
you're in that mode of like i love it
and i want to do it all the time do it
yeah but if you're not there anymore it
feels like torture yeah right yeah
that's where we were with our reaction
video
exactly
to do something yeah by your audience or
by whoever
it takes it takes a bit of the fun out
of that i i reckon that at some point
like a fun game might come out and then
boom i'll just be streaming it every day
but at least i'll do that when i want to
yeah when i feel forced to but i'm just
going to see if pvp got back to me nope
we have a lawyer that we you know pmp
the guy who um let's go let's go let's
go guy who's like this dude got three
homicides he crashed into a house
fell into the child's bed i don't know
bless the child we got him off no jail
time let's go
oh well let me show you on
[Music]
um well he he we were trying to get him
to call in but i guess i wanted to find
out if jerking your dog off is illegal
or not i'm interested too i wanna i need
a legal analysis
i'll just show you my favorite pnp i
mean everybody's seen these who watches
but
this is just it's so [ __ ] good dude
you're gonna love wait is this the guy
that you did facetime at some point we
talked to him yeah yeah yeah i i
remember okay wow really i do have a lot
of time to watch
bro i
love i am like chronically listening to
something it's probably bad but i listen
to the podcast a lot because i think you
guys are one of the only
podcasts that is like long-form streamed
and talks about like current events pop
culture internet stuff like really are
there even that many i don't think
anyone makes as much content as us
that's for sure true like you guys talk
about all the topics things i haven't
even heard of honestly
whenever i have the time i put it on
yeah
it's great and it it kind of feels like
just
uh just like overhearing it's friends
conversations yeah i love it that's the
[Laughter]
you've kept them
family i on know if you guys can see dan
is using a giant
clothesline
i thought it was a boom mic
this is a boom holder but that's [ __ ]
oh okay
damn a massive
glasses on it's called a c-stand
actually all right a c-stand thing we
love a good c-stand
for like overhead shots
thank you oh yeah that's nice actually i
love that
oh yeah
oh yeah baby
zach don't don't don't tell me [ __ ]
don't [ __ ] this up for you it sounds
good okay thank you
beautiful
all right let me just show you this and
then let's talk about angie's favorite
all right this is just my favorite song
i forgot what we were going to talk
about yeah all right we're right outside
of van nuys courthouse i got my great
client here he was charged with a second
time dui
uh he admittedly overdosed on multiple
different drugs that night because of
drug-induced psychosis he crashed with
two other cars on a freeway and flipped
over a few times luckily everyone made
it out all right
the fire department came with the police
used the jaws of life dragged him out of
the car and started fighting with them
they charged him with resisting arrest
also
um
and we're pleased to announce that he's
getting out of this with just a wet
a reckless driving one year of probation
not five years that is normally given in
a second time dui and most importantly
he's really changed his life around he
put himself in rehab
immediately after this happened he's
been in for nine months he does meetings
every single day and he's really turned
his life around how are you feeling i'm
feeling great thank you so much david
for everything i've done
all right that's the weirdest part
[Applause]
this dude's unleashing super villains
bro is never going to get a job after
this big buck
that's so [ __ ] true nah this ain't
right that's why he had the mask up he
was like i can't let him know it's me
yeah so there you go this is our boy pmp
friend of the show let's go let's go
all right let's talk about andrew tate
i don't know how much you've talked
about or this whole phenomenon maybe
took place when you were on your break
yes oh okay literally okay i left
and throughout that month that's when
andrew tate became more popular
and then i think god did me a solid
seriously right before i came back gonzo
so you know
they'd be the hassle of talking about
all this but all right let's get into it
so you were following it all so what was
your thoughts on watching that all
happen from afar
[Music]
i think a part of me loki i was like
you know
it was like seeing the insoles rise up
again i was like i need to come back
right now
oh you wanted to come back
the only reason he even
had his rise you were the bulwark and
without him
when
i think
i think to me it just made me really sad
because
i thought
as
internet users we had kind of moved past
this sort of
this sort of talk this sort of misogyny
this sort of rhetoric
and to see it come back and rise up in
such a massive manner i guess was yeah
just surprising and kind of sad to see
especially in regards to the harassment
that it resulted in
but something that i think people don't
discuss enough is
clearly there must be a lot of
especially young men who for some reason
resonate with what andrew tate is saying
why is that and are there any takeaways
that we can take from that in order to
not have things snowball so far out of
control in the future right yeah that's
a good question i i also agree i didn't
know where the i didn't know this thing
was even brewing i mean you see a lot of
small fries like fresh and fit who are
like small-time misogynists
and rolo tony browntown who's like an
even smaller town
misogynist but andrew tate is like
just became so big and i agree i don't
know
obviously there's he's a symptom of a
problem yeah and i'm not quite sure
why
young men in america or around the world
even are so [ __ ]
dissatisfied
you know what i think it might be
actually
i think there might be some things he
says
because obviously i really have not seen
much of his content so i'm kind of going
off of the reactions of people
i think there must be some things he
says just like general life advice
perhaps
that does resonate with people or
provide value
but then i think he takes it too far
sometimes as a gimmick or for the memes
or for the laughs or for the whatever
right yeah
but i guess to me it just shows like
young men must not have many people to
listen to or many people that are giving
them advice like this role models yeah
many role models that are kind of
guiding them
and i'm sure
like you know there are issues for that
both genders face and clearly young
dudes you know
they need some assistance i guess i
don't know what is wrong are they not
getting enough love at home you know i
mean
are men not being nurtured by their
fathers and they might not be yeah they
might not be ever since it became such a
big thing like the more we talk about it
to people in our life
not on the internet just people they
all have a story of like oh yeah this
guy was just telling me that he really
looks up to
tate yeah
and so it really enriched like a lot of
people exactly and when i hear stuff
like that i'm like i'm curious what
content of andrews that they're
referring to yeah because i feel like
there's such a spectrum i don't know
well that's the self help aspect is so
like
uh generic
anyone can do it you know deliver the
same [ __ ] uh but i think tried and
true like self-help stuff nice people
deliver it in a nice way and he delivers
it in a very sensationalized manner
which works for some folks well it's
nice to think that everything bad in
your life isn't your fault i mean jordan
peterson does the same thing
but i don't know i don't know if men
from this generation like were just
didn't get enough [ __ ] love like
women or young girls their parents
nurture them in general on being general
but i think it's true where young girls
see an affection and specifically from
dads let's say
uh that young boys probably maybe that's
not as true
now
i think that's changed a bit where where
people my age and younger are feeling
more comfortable being sensitive and
loving to to their child to their boys
but i wonder if um
boys did not get enough nurturing i
really do i don't know you know aside
from just parental nurturing
i wonder what friendships
between
men ages like 14 to 21 look like
i'm really curious
because i feel like when i see guys who
have really healthy friendships people
that they can be vulnerable with
people that they can talk to
people that they can hug every now and
then if they need a hug i feel like it
makes such a difference in just like how
well-rounded they are as a human being
that's very true but again it's like
we need to you guys need to bring on
like a 15 year old andrew tate fanboy
interview him see what's up
extrapolate some information we've seen
them they're just like him they don't
[ __ ] listen like sneak oh i've heard
him debate people
you just he's all
he's older
he's older but he's not as old as me but
i think they're just i mean it's like
almost like a mega
level of deluge like cultist delusion
like there's there's really once they've
fallen into the table there's almost no
sense
they've lost all sense of it makes me
kind of scared
being in an industry that is like so
adjacent to that like gaming
streaming
i don't know yeah but i think i think
there's a lot of toxic masculinity which
jordan i know i'm sorry jordan peterson
toxic masculinity
what the [ __ ] does that mean
your impression is so good thank you
finally somebody admits that
everybody makes fun of my it's okay no
what is the meaning of justice no
is it just the other well oh wasn't as
good [ __ ] you what did i do
[ __ ] you pokey
toxic masculinity you're doing it wrong
what does that mean
yeah but i think toxic masculinity
really just comes from men not being
nurtured enough i do i see people in the
chat resonating with that and there's
like here's a couple saying like think
back young men or men my age think back
to how your dad my dad was [ __ ] not
my dad would never tell me like he loves
me just like that for example not that i
didn't no but i mean you know like
there's no [ __ ] personal loving
connection there
uh uh and i think it was like that for
all my friends and their dads too it's
like you know it's this old school thing
of the the moon go to work and our
emotional black holes
and we just provide and it's the
mother's job to nurture the boys
but that's just half of the [ __ ] boys
need their dads a lot i think guys need
i don't know if this sounds weird guys
need love from guys too if it's your dad
if it's your friend
like
you need to have other men in your life
that you can speak to honestly share
your troubles
learn from each other grow together
this is daddy issues i think is what
we're seeing and you know what else i
think it is i think there's been such a
like female empowerment movement
that when you're young if you're like a
12 year old boy you don't really
understand the history of the women's
movement
or why
women say certain things or express
certain difficulties that they go
through
why other women support women so much or
why some guys go out of their way to
support women right it's because of this
historic
you know these issues that we've had in
the past but if you're literally 10 and
you see this you're like women are
treated so much better than men you know
like you just don't get it and then i
think i feel like they're fighting back
against that a little bit like wait
there's these double standards things
are not fair when in in reality
they don't understand the full context
yeah they don't i hope that makes sense
no it does ela what were you gonna say
[Music]
they were saying like um i saw a few
that they were they grew up in
such a way that they're they're doing a
lot of like unlearning now and re
thinking
and they still need to do it because
it's um
we all grew up like that
and there's a lot of changing to do
when you as a man come very close to a
woman whether it's romantic or a sibling
and you
you experience like a real closeness
them
like with eli i learned so much from her
just about
there's certain situations you find
yourself in where you don't feel safe
around men constantly things that you
have to worry about that i totally get
um you you brought up a lot of uh good
examples that i can't recall like what
what are some examples you know that men
would nev men like this they don't even
think about what what it's like to live
like that i mean i like getting an uber
yeah we're talking recently just any
situation where you're one-on-one with a
guy right it can be anywhere it can be
just walking in the street
at night guys behind you yeah uber
elevator
cat calls you yeah
demanding attention from you like having
to have a technician at home you know oh
yeah or anything that's like one-on-one
is really scary
really scary hear all these horror
stories all the time if it's a friend a
family member or a stranger and so like
as a woman you're constantly being told
like be on guard and so we kind of have
to be
yeah
even like trying to make friends that
are guys you have to be so careful
especially like
can i hang out with him one on one is he
going to consider it a date is it this
is it that like every little thing you
don't want guys to take the wrong way
obviously
you know but i mean obviously women are
already they're now even now being
challenged for their rights i mean
of bodily autonomy so
true it's a little bit no actually just
to share an experience within gaming
that
i feel like
growing up i didn't understand women's
issues that much because i lived in like
middle buff like nowhere went to a small
elementary school small high school just
grew up kind of like
normal kind of naive once i entered the
gaming space
and especially once i started blowing up
within gaming that's when i truly
started understanding the nuances
and the differences in how men and women
can be treated both by men and women and
one of the things that was so hard for
me to come to terms with
was
when i felt like i was being treated
unfairly especially in the beginning
like 2018 2019
and i could tell even though
i had men in my life and in the industry
that i knew so well and that i was close
to
i could sense that they had such a fear
and avoidance of speaking up
for me because they were scared that
they would be called a simp or a white
knight or whatever it's the same thing
and if you think about it like if you're
afraid
i feel like that
that's so unfortunate you're scared to
speak up for your friend due to their
gender
like as a girl it makes me think well
god damn i wish i was a guy so you
wouldn't mind like backing me up they're
scared of their fans yeah which you know
and it was just such a sad realization
to come to or a sad thing to even be
told from people yeah or by people so
yeah they don't want to be targeted by
the [ __ ] yeah goons out there but
it's also like the more
the more
you avoid that the more you're letting
them win like you're letting that
narrative win yeah no i totally agree
i mean that's part of the reason why
so many [ __ ] people hate me on the
internet is because
i really you know yeah you stand up for
whatever the hell speaks to speak my
true thoughts and there was a time
when i would avoid talking about certain
things i was like oh the my fans
are gonna [ __ ]
be so pissed at me and i think
over time on this podcast we've i've
been able to shed that thing and
actually we just cultivated fans who
um
are tolerant of that i completely agree
because like as a fan yeah i i've seen
you guys like over time discuss so many
topics and i just come to understand
like one i think it's amazing that
you're not afraid of any topic you're
not afraid to tread on any ground really
and two like even if at some point as a
viewer i disagree or i don't or whatever
i will still nonetheless respect the
fact that you're willing to put your
opinion out there because a lot of the
time it does make a big difference
that you're down to talk about those
topics that other people won't
yeah thank you but yeah i think i think
i think it's
part of the problem with why i was going
crazy is because i knew that we were
guarding a lot of reactionary fans that
i [ __ ] hated and what do you mean
reactionary things like uh
conservative uh
[ __ ]
like all right racist
racist uh
from i was doing like a lot of social
justice warrior stuff back in the day
you know like the ac thing and the
humongous thing
and so whenever i would express
an opinion that was like
a little bit liberal or something it was
like
[ __ ] lip [ __ ] and it just turned
into this whole thing
and uh i just realized that i was
starting to hate my fans
i was like these people suck i don't
want to [ __ ] turn into
some weird freak that just caters to
them
and so it was an important realization
to make it was and it was painful there
was years and years of just everybody
everybody hating us get out i mean you
guys know you were there in the trenches
with me dan mor dan the beginning of the
podcast was really rough
yeah there was a there was some growing
pains i guess you could call it as you
sort of shed that the vestiges of that
part of your fan base but
you know we got through it we came out
the other side stronger we call them
fallen fans they're easy to spot
i miss you anyway that's it but um
they're the strongest haters
but um
yeah i've always thought it was
difficult to be a woman on the internet
like people think
it's so easy and it's like a cheat code
or something but
um
it's really and it's a male dominated
don't you love that when somebody wants
to diss you they have to call you ugly
like i get that a lot too oh yeah that
was
not too thick and you can just
ugly not funny content sucks and it's
like just move on
it's funny because they'll both say
people only like you for your looks but
you're ugly
make it make sense amazing decide which
one is it it's not adding up which one
is it
yeah andrew tate actually made a video
calling hila ugly
oh how dare he yeah yeah no we have a
pretty good thing going on but that's it
people whenever whenever these bros get
angry at me they always go after ila and
call her ugly which is like
the silliest way to try to insult me
because i know objective they're
insulting me when they do that they're
not hungry
it's the biggest self report
[Laughter]
keemstar calls her keemstar does the
horse
which makes me so
angry a [ __ ] loser and i mean what
can you say
like the dude is dating a [ __ ] uh 18
years and one day year old what makes me
sad is like he's he's a father right
yeah you know i'm not sure i've had
mixed
he was dating this woman oh who he broke
up with and i'm still not sure if that's
his biological daughter or it was his
ex-girlfriend's daughter do we have any
intel on that ab
i'm not sure honestly
it was his biological daughter that's
what i thought too for a long time
but all of a sudden
is she still with him the daughter
because she would always show her and
yeah he's still yeah he does do that
yeah yeah he is so let's say he's a dad
yeah i mean he he raised her right
as a father it
it makes me so sad to see someone who's
a dad not understand the repercussions
of insulting a woman's appearance only
you disagree with someone or you don't
like them and that's the one thing you
go after
if you don't understand that i don't
have a lot of faith
no offense in you to raise your daughter
with like love and compassion of course
not he's a monster dude
but that was one of the big things that
i always thought was so funny that like
leafy and keemstar they're like oh two
out of ten or something what was the
thing that you said yeah
you know what maybe someday as he's
raising his daughter maybe he'll
understand if she comes home and she's
like dad this this guy said this you'll
understand what that
but there that's the effect that it can
have on something there's such goblins
though
like have you seen i'm gonna be honest
the kid is a [ __ ] goblin yeah i don't
take it that personally
right i'm just saying you know the
saying that's like uh only take advice
from people you admire
you know in that capacity i can't say i
admire yourself
it's okay yeah yeah everyone's entitled
to their opinion
yeah exactly if you ask if you ask
keemstar and his
these kids are pimply faced and just
[ __ ] like undateable [ __ ] losers
and the same month they go let's see
pokey is a two ela's a horse and lena's
a witch it's like
looks like i've got a throne and oh
get your eyesight checked holy [ __ ]
oh my gosh i feel very foolish it really
doesn't it doesn't i don't find it
offensive though because well first of
all it's they're insulting either so
it's up to you but i don't think no i
don't do at all i don't it's like i find
it funny it's funny yeah it's like how
do you care what do i care what you
think how attractive she is i don't know
less so than that and i i wouldn't even
go after their looks personally for me
it just makes me sad they're kind of
like brainwashing their young audience
to
just regurgitate similar insults towards
women whereas it's like
simultaneously say chauvinism it doesn't
exist yeah if you have an issue with
someone and they are a girl that's okay
but just think about it why do i not
like them
and is that reason reasonable
don't just jump straight to you make me
feel weird so you're ugly like the [ __ ]
well when you say someone's ugly as an
insult you're reducing that person down
to their physical appearance being their
only redeeming attribute and then the
same people go
misogyny doesn't exist it's like you're
[ __ ] so brain dead you're so lost in
your own mannosphere
[ __ ] uh abyss hole that you you'll
never you'll never get a date you'll you
will only ever
[ __ ] a fleshlight
and you know that's there's nothing
wrong with that because at this why do
women get all the fun toys and men's got
a [ __ ] [ __ ] fleshlight it's not
fair but it is what it is i've been like
the emotional part you'll never
emotionally bond with that fleshlight as
at least as far as i'm aware better than
jerking off a dog
i'm busting i i try to be a little more
optimistic like i hope i hope someday
you fall in love and someone loves you
and you can be happier and then you will
likely not talk like that to other
people
i really feel like if you have
experienced good love in life
you're just not one of those folks
no that's it maybe said years later
people are still calling
lena a witch which is insane i mean
that's all chemicals where literally
where we posted a picture on my
instagram yeah and someone said it'd be
hilarious if that uh rock fell on that
wicked witch
yeah jesus yeah you guys are always
super humble
talking about your name
but oh yeah let's see
i'm kidding i'm kidding i'm kidding
let's find your mommy i just yeah i just
want to talk
yeah
though i don't think they have an
account anymore
what lena it doesn't bother me other
than like
the way that they think that it would
get to us describing their physical
appearance it doesn't get to me like
they think it does yeah it's just wild
because at the time we weren't even
hired by you guys which is insane that
he just went after nobody's like yeah
also can i please say you are three of
literally the hottest women ever
like that is the most ridiculous it's so
funny it just it shows how but that like
yeah it's just elbows too pointy
it's literally the hat oh my god
what is that oh my listen i've been an
internet goblin for a very long time and
there used to be this meme where it's
essentially a guy like
uh yeah trying to like insult a woman
and he's like her elbows are too pointy
four out of ten like elbows too pointy
with a [ __ ]
these dudes like barely interact with
women and yet they think their standards
should be up there
yeah it's beyond me well the good news
is you know there's lots there's a huge
variety of fleshlights on the market now
so you'll be able to cycle through those
and
again the emotional part is the part i'm
worried about them
i wish them the best peace and love
i hope you move past this phase of your
life yeah yeah grow out of it yeah but i
do want to talk about i have to pee i
got to do that when i come back i will
show you guys the cease and desist that
andrew that was supposed to talk about
sent us have you read it do you want me
to read it out while you're peeing i
haven't read it yet
i'll read it
but
talk amongst yourselves
any questions from the chat any
questions from the crew what's up crew
oh yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
do you have any spicy things you're
curious about ama
i'm here
i was just curious if you pronounce your
name iman or
uh i maybe try to answer that because my
sister's name is iman and she always was
a fan of you so the arabic way yeah
actually if anything in arabic it's a
bit more like amen amen right yes
which means faith yeah
which i love so cute you speak arabic
so i speak the moroccan dialect there's
like a billion dialects in arabic
so if someone speaks a different kind of
arabic sometimes i can pick up on like
certain words
but not all of it really
sadly yeah i'm the same way yeah me too
i always say that because um i only
speak mainly lebanese dialect yeah most
people kind of speak standard and i have
a difficult time understanding standard
arabic i would love to learn standard we
would really like later
yeah
you know my gran grandparents spoke
arabic and i wish that i learned but
i think when they started israel it was
kind of like everybody speak hebrew
because we you know the the pride the
beef yeah take the time to actually
learn it
it's hard i want to learn arabic and
spanish oh yeah i want to learn spanish
is a bit easier because i know french
okay that's cool
lebanese people love
to speak french they always want to
learn from morocco too because it was a
french colony right yeah that's where i
learned it yeah i really love to learn
to speak swedish maybe love you
you love the swedes yes sir
swedish is uh pretty hard because it's
so unliteral we'll say for example
uh jump in bed that means go go to bed
uh i don't know
i've heard a lot of people say that i
have a question actually
some content that i've really been
enjoying uh from you is the
interviews with people uh like uh xqc
and uh
the mini podcast yes i love them so much
super like probably my favorite content
on twitch right now uh you don't do them
too often are you are you planning on
doing more i think i might be doing one
with miss kiff in like a week or two oh
exciting
secret intel if it works
you bring you bring i don't know they
they're never uh like super emotion
emotional they never show that side of
themself and you kind of bring them uh
bring that out of them i think it's
pretty interesting dude you ask
streamers stuff and you'll be baffled by
the kind of stuff that they tell you i
think a lot of top streamers
guys like don't have that many close
friends unfortunately and for people
that are so popular and have so much in
their life right it really makes me
wonder like i'm sure a lot of guys feel
a similar type of loneliness
yeah so yeah
anyways thank you for enjoying that
appreciate it
more to come more to come
awesome
so
here's the letter and again let's get
into it it's worth noting
first of all they put a 24-hour deadline
on this to remove all offending content
assist it went to my lawyer spam box for
three days
and they didn't say [ __ ]
rip and then when my when my lawyer
decided to go through a spam box he's
like oh [ __ ] i got a
uh spam from this [ __ ]
what do you know what that smell is but
it smells so good
just smells fresh laundry is it my hands
yeah maybe this is blowing right out
it smells really good thank you you want
to smell my hands eva
yes what is that
[Music]
i smell my hunger i want to smell feet
yeah so that's the first sailor that's
the first funny thing about it
the second funny thing is
anyone that was following this knows
that
andrew tate has been crying about his
right for to free speech frieza and a
lot of conservatives and all the people
defending him influencers big and small
people that i some people that i even
like and respect or who are like
yo i don't believe what what andrew tate
says but i defend his freedom of speech
i'm like okay no bro stop it no can i
say something real quick yeah
i saw this tick tock pop up on my for
you page
it was like
ladies
go to andrew tate's instagram
and then click on like the following
followers whatever and then you can go
to mutuals or something
and you see
all the guys that you follow that follow
him
you guys were doing that right
did you see any that surprised you a lot
of phase boys no surprise
i called my friend who has a little
brother who followed him and i was like
we gotta figure out what's happening
right now
talk to him yeah listen i i you know i
can't say you know andrew tate maybe
doesn't bring value to someone's life
but after everything that's occurred i
think you can also very clearly see what
his views on women are
and in my opinion like if you follow him
you might agree with that you know i
can't say one to one but
no no interesting intel
you're less informed i'd say because you
were on break you said you haven't seen
all this stuff it's one to one
it is crazy no it's like radical
chauvinism it's like radical violent
chauvinism
i consider him to be a hate group and if
someone's following him that's a [ __ ]
cry for help that's crazy i agree
legitimate intervention is needed you
know that instagram is public when you
follow yeah not just that like
you're a public streamer person with
millions of followers that's crazy
yes so
he's crying about his freedom of speech
these guys are all freedom of speech
warriors you know uh
so so what does it mean now when i'm
criticizing him
fairly exercising my first amendment
rights of to free speech like these
people care about and love so well
what does it mean when andrew tate is
sending me a cease and desist demanding
i stop talking about him immediately
what do we think about this i haven't
seen one free speech warrior speak up
uh and say that andrew's a [ __ ]
hypocritical loser
that's the game that's the game
that is the game you know i'm and people
say oh you're not
pro free speech i am the free speech
king and i declare that here and now
someone give him a question he's like my
third defamation lawsuit if he sues me
look at me good fellow citizens
i have strengthened your right to use
free speech on youtube and all around
the world that's true i am the free
speech king i have never litigated i
have never sued anyone i have never
compelled speech in my life
and by the way all the people that sue
me are conservatives let's see who's
really in favor of free speech matt haas
i don't know for sure
we don't know i don't know for sure
he's mad
[ __ ] yes uh ryan
from yesterday oh yeah thank you yeah
those are those are bangers that's like
mario
thank you i saw i heard that a lot i'll
take it it's very exciting um and ela's
giving luigi vibes too actually
is she i don't know she's like she's not
not in the man but in the like she's
tall and slender oh like luigi
too pretty
amazing oh wow bow to me you
conservative pigs
i am your king your ruler the one true
god of free speech suck a little bit of
dick brian kavanaugh's maggot he sued me
for defamation
and all kinds of [ __ ] and now andrew
tate who's obviously magga is
threatening to sue me and i hope he does
so that i can prove to you all right now
who the king of free speech is and i
invite all of you
get on your knees and suck my
tiny jewish free speech appointed dick
and bald suck a little bit specifically
my gnarly ass balls only if you're
wearing a dick rick owens i have a
little hole for you guys i can still
remain fully clothed while you do it
right now it doesn't exist someone asked
if you could try the entertain um accent
i'm not good at it
i know i know i'm just not good at it
i'm not good at the english accent watch
i saw aidan ross posted like mrs andrew
tate's last message and i clicked it and
it was an hour long yes and i clicked
off did you guys watch that yeah yeah we
did we watched everything
can i get a tldr oh it's so bad
the tldr is just that oh
he's crying and being like yo i wasn't
that serious and people are taking it
out of context and he's lying and he
keeps like flexing too i live the good
life
acting like he
died yeah like an obituary for himself
it was very strange for someone who like
you know he had his whole
business ponzi
he had his thing the hustle thing yeah
and he has people like reposting his
content but i assume he has garnered
quite an understanding of how content
functions i was so surprised that for
his last message he chose for it to be
an hour long like if you want to appeal
to people who don't it was so bad yeah
if you want to appeal to people who
disagree with you
you shouldn't make it an hour long like
make it a little more digestible well it
did work because he was on fox news
later
tucker carlson who has continued to talk
about him by the way he's like a
champion over on fox news somehow they
don't care about anything he's said or
done anything about fox news bro they're
just like you know anything about fox
news nada tucker who they're a bunch of
uh i hope he doesn't take that person
white supremacist [ __ ] freaks no he's
he doesn't care
anyway sorry go on so anyway let's get
into
the season wait a second
as a viewer yeah i gotta call you out on
this i feel like you've said this is
gonna be the last time you're talking
about andrew tate
[ __ ]
[Applause]
don't get your feelings hurt because i
watch
[Laughter]
i was going to move on which is ironic
because he's trying to get me to stop
talking about him and then he says
receiving this is and i'm like shut the
f okay well let's go
the door was almost closed it was just
like literally there was just like a
little slit it was almost closed if
you're gonna like sue someone for not
talking about you number one not ethan
klein know your opponent please
are you kidding me
you did not do this
i'm tired of talking about him i don't
want to talk about him a lot of people
were saying they have conspiracy
theories oh well he heard you're going
to stop talking about him and he said
that i don't see how that benefits him i
don't think he really likes me talking
about him because i literally am telling
people this man is a human trafficker
and you know i'm a proponent of getting
him de-platform so i don't see how it
benefits him
for me to keep talking about him i don't
know maybe you're conspiracy theorist
with that stuff what do you think
uh whatever you say boss
i don't have one for this specific one i
usually say when i have one so so say
that don't say whatever you say boss
sorry make him seem like he always good
whatever
gary
dude no i appreciate you asking i i
don't have one for this what do you say
whatever you say both
maybe he gives examples on this i hope
otherwise i'm confused here's the cease
and desist
uh he sent it to me he says request a
cease and desist all defamation slander
and or libel of character of reputation
notice of deliberate misuse dear
respondents
i am the rep if you are the
the representative legal counsel please
direct this uh letter to your attorney
blah blah blah blah
yadda yadda i represent mr andrew tay
yadda yadda yadda you are hereby notifi
notified to cease and desist any further
unlawful defamation slander or liewa
yadda yadda yap you have to uh
specifically through the date of august
he was really angry about this one
because it got like 300 000 likes
and so tweet brave to have um
so brave to have this sex trafficking
violent misogynist rapist on and i got
like 350 000 likes so he's saying um he
also says on july 21st and a title
biting okova jordan peter's obsession
with right wing comedy which was viewed
more than
890 thousand times oh tell them
shout me out baby
said the following we talked a lot about
cobra tate we had some internal dialogue
what is the best way to represent
one who is known as a human trafficker
womanizer violent womanizing freak
uh yeah that was it you know how he
really made his money before all that he
was a human traffic digital pimp you
know that like uh the american embassy
raided his compound because he was
holding women against their will yeah
bro he is literally human trafficker
he's really that person he's frankly
scary someone who's [ __ ]
up is out there and wait this they're
saying his information he's really that
person it's frankly scary someone like
that [ __ ] up is out there and he is
out there
really that
okay that's the game
he's a violent uh human-hating cultish
freak
again
come on you're stretching that one this
dude literally says he pays off the
police there rape laws are relaxed there
he said that he literally said that a
lot of this stuff i'm clueless but i did
see that yeah you're talking about a guy
who brags about buying off the police
there the american government said
earlier yo this guy's literally
kidnapping women forcing them into
webcam
sex slavery
he just points out a lot of stuff like
this but what's interesting what's my
favorite thing and obviously i already
talked this over with my lawyers like
easy anti-slap gg so [ __ ] sue me like
literally i don't give a [ __ ]
like here
literally type andrew tape human
trafficking oops
[ __ ] yes
let's see inside the violent
misogynistic world of tick tock's new
start man the guardian that's like a
huge publication right violent
misogynistic world of tick tock's new
star andrew tate okay
interesting andrew tate human traffic
allegations explained
okay there's another one here's another
one andrew tate claims he was swatted
well that's yeah that's what he said
[ __ ] liar ass [ __ ]
andrew tate mega king of toxic
masculinity
raided and human trafficking violation
um dude
yeah i'm not making this [ __ ] up it's
all over the internet
uh another one
angie tate's house raided in romania on
charges of human trafficking after you
allegedly kidnapped an american woman i
mean tate are you really trying to put
make this [ __ ] a pub matter of public
record just
just accept that you're a human
trafficker bro just be proud of it just
be proud of it that that's your whole
selling point no well he was he was
probably lost everything yeah exactly
yeah yeah you're a human trafficker bro
just just
man you're like you're like the bad guy
from taken
[Laughter]
you know we love and we love that about
you you're a violent misogynist there's
a video online of him beating the [ __ ]
out of a woman huh
yes
that's what i've seen it that's what i'm
saying bro defamation of what of
character you're such a [ __ ] it's
impossible to defame your character
this is all real [ __ ] man i'm a man of
god
yeah by the way i'm a man of god all of
a sudden in his apology video he was
like talking about how i'm a man of god
and if god wants me to have a twitter
i'll have a twitter
he got so canceled he found jesus
well yeah so
he's a public figure his fans are like
well freedom speech doesn't protect you
lying about people he's a public figure
this shit's all
he's a human trafficker i mean the
allegations are there it's he wasn't
disproven i think you just gotta throw
in a few allegations
allegedly
i think it's all there there
cherry-picked it you know we showed the
articles okay but he's he is known to me
as andrew the human trafficker tate
and i thought he liked that but
apparently not
actually this
is reminding me of this clip i saw
yesterday do you guys know um
nick is not green yeah yeah did you guys
see what he posted on twitter yesterday
yes the chat chat thing the sneaker
thing i love chad chad by the way
i love her i don't know what is it girl
pull that [ __ ] up it was literally so
disturbing
i was actually baffled yeah
it was sneako talking about chad chad
posted a video about all the misogynists
online i want to reiterate like i don't
know much about either of these guys
because of pieces
but that video really surprised me i
know too much i don't know if it's like
gonna get us age restricted
but in the video he was like shut up
[ __ ] you're being dramatic you just
haven't got enough good dick and then he
acts like he's choking her out on camera
and i don't know
he's a he's a andrew tate he looks up to
andrew tate that's like his idol he
simulates pretty much sexual assault on
the camera and aimed it at a creator
i wonder if youtube's done anything
about it
um
yeah she's great
she's hilarious she posts uh like
response videos so he was talking about
her yeah yeah
her content is so funny
shout out so creative so well made
so i don't know i i would love to see
ela's reaction in the video but if i'll
shout i can't do it it's okay ban him
from the platform
to be fair if they allowed a normal
video
do you guys think this is uh
just trigger warning maybe you don't
need to be cut away when he starts doing
like the the miming of
assaulting her you can just take it off
camera yeah
but today i want to briefly talk about
yeah this guy uh what's his name uh uh
he's he's a good good dude i like his
girlfriend
nick is not green content creator sneako
and ask youtube to ban him from the
platform i'm going to keep this video
really short because i just want to say
my piece and give sneako and his fans as
little ammunition to fire back as
possible because we know that every time
someone utters his name on youtube he
feels the need to make five videos
crying about women and society or
whatever and before we begin i do want
to say that most of the time i don't
believe that deep platforming someone is
the proper way to deal with the
controversy a lot of times creators that
i disagree with on a personal level are
mostly harmless and i don't believe that
disagreeing with someone's personal
values are ground for removal from
youtube or twitch or any other social
media platform in general policing
content can be dangerous but as you're
about to see sneako has grossly violated
youtube's terms of service and qualifies
for removal from the website now i'm not
going to go into too much depth here but
if you don't already know who sneako is
he is a gaming and commentary content
creator who continues to spread
extremely harmful messages to a rapidly
growing audience usually violently
ranting about women politics or men
wearing makeup he's sort of like the new
andrew tate now that he's not on the
platform anymore he was recently banned
off twitter and now has two channel
strikes on youtube but i'm not exactly
sure what the reason for that is now a
little over a month ago
he's basically not the nazi and i know
people overuse that he what they were
talking on his stream about how uh
how uh the jewish question about uh jews
running everything and
basically like really deep anti-semitic
[ __ ] so
there is no way
yeah yeah
yeah it's all connected this shit's all
connected too you know like this
conservative womanizing chauvinism it's
like a direct [ __ ] that's crazy a
direct
line into the veins of uh white
nationalism and anti-semitism and all
that my friends chad chad who gave me
permission to make this video but had no
part in the creation of it and it wasn't
her idea or suggestion for me to make
this he reacted to a video she made
about a tick tock dating coach and i'm
just going to play the video here so
nothing can be left out of context but i
am going to issue a huge content warning
for sexual assault so if that's
something that you're uncomfortable with
in any way i would leave the video now
you know what's so funny about the
internet
it hides the fact and like this feminist
garbage hides the fact that she's
attracted to that guy making the videos
it is what it is girls you could vouch
for it you know it's true she would
she would and you know sister was so
predictable you could tell by the way
she's talking that she hasn't been
properly
in a long time it's been a while so
she's on the internet making this
garbage video promoting all those
feminist garbage to your [ __ ] lonely
girls in the comments section what you
really need chat chat is
yeah shut up shut up with your feminism
yeah come here come here
that's what you need and she's gonna go
that's what you need you need some sense
to [ __ ] back into you and you know what
they're gonna do right after they do
that they're gonna i didn't even
remember
but you know it's true you can hear it
in her voice she hasn't been properly
[Music]
in too long and now you make no sense
that's what happens man
that's what happens yo someone vouched
for me you know it's true no i don't
think i have to explain he's a dream
he's a dreamboat isn't he
i think they're just spamming l for her
because they love that [ __ ] i like to
think it's for him
oh nick's in the chat what's uh you just
became a member let's go
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
can i just say for anyone watching at
home
the audio is bad it still doesn't do the
video justice like seeing it yeah
he simulates hitting her and choking her
and he stimulates her being like scared
i'm so confused honestly when i see
stuff like this i
what i see is someone
who honestly is trying really hard to
appease and entertain
an audience that just wants them to be
more and more extreme mm-hmm that like
they don't even realize how [ __ ] up
the things that they're doing
i see it as a feedback loop yeah the
audience yeah demands him to get more
extreme yeah and he can never walk
anything back or they'll turn on them
yeah so it's like they get worse and
worse and versus
cycle dude
yeah but i think he's a perfect
dreamboat i always dreamed
dreamboat what's that yeah he's just
dreamy he's perfect
nick
no [ __ ] uh uh uh sneako i always
dreamed of having a dad who beats the
[ __ ] out of my mom
you know beats me leaves when i'm
[ __ ] five dreamboats yeah what's a
dream
like like he's a hottie a dream come
true yeah okay it is a little
uh it is making the joke
he's awesome
he's like nick is on the screen
oh my god he's chillin
with me
no he's dreamy he's dreamy too but not
the same way
i've always dreamed
let me make my joke please i've always
dreamed
of having a dad like like sneako who
beats the [ __ ] on my mom yeah beats the
[ __ ] out of me leaves when i'm five it
starts a new family i'm being honest
that's who he's role playing at he's
role-playing as like a toxic [ __ ]
disgusting
joke
house ruining dad it's not bad
and he's saying yo you know you want to
[ __ ] me like he's
he's he's the perfect man you're kind of
delivering it in the same way you
deliver things that you actually mean
i was getting there
okay yeah the flow is gone the flow is
gone it's okay all right the dreamboat
these things happen dreamboat
i saw someone say he's a doom canoe and
i really like that that's he's a
doomfist
it's every child's fantasy
you know you know you want
is every girl's dream that's what he
acts like he's like you know you want a
guy who's going to destroy your life the
problem is that i think that the people
who listen actually do think that
and that's not funny yeah but they're
none of my business
i'll let nick finish the video because
he does uh do a call to action here
explain why this is disgusting sneako is
harassing a female content creator
telling her that the reason why she's so
upset is because she hasn't had sex in a
while and then he proceeds to
aggressively simulate a sexual assault
on chad chad in his live stream in front
of thousands of people and like i said
there are creators who i disagree with
and then there are people like sneko who
actively threaten other creators on
youtube spread hate speech and overall
make youtube the less enjoyable and more
dangerous place for everybody who's on
it not to mention that this clip alone
obviously violates youtube's community
guidelines around harassment youtube has
banned creators even recently for much
less and i think that this is an obvious
instance of a creator who is now causing
more harm by existing on this site and
this isn't even about free speech this
is about taking action when a content
creator spreads messaging like this and
i think youtube would agree that someone
like this definitely does not belong on
their platform if you watch this video
and you also believe that sneako should
be banned from youtube you can go to his
channel pages click about and then click
the flag icon on the right side of the
page and report the user thank you for
watching have a nice day
and i'm doing that right now he's like
it's like a ranking listen if you think
he should be reported then go for it
you know i i kind of appreciate that
people are willing to say that because
for the longest time
if you said i've never seen someone say
that that's it's like oh you can never
call someone out you can never call for
someone to lose sponsors you can never
call for someone to go oh you're for
deep platforming it's like
never ever do it
but my point about that is like
everybody's for deep platforming it's
just a matter of where you draw the line
because
i don't think most of these guys are for
isis having a youtube channel right i
just couldn't i couldn't believe i saw i
saw that with my uh my very own eyes i
don't know which is worse that or this
freeway prolapse
that yeah that okay yeah there it is
yeah something that i've seen a trend
that i see recently that i find kind of
bothersome
um i see a lot of people especially in
regards to twitch
compare sexual content
with a variety of other things like
they're like oh my god i see boobs on
twitch but like this person can't be on
twitch and it's like they're very
different things and it makes me realize
how conditioned we've been to think that
like sexual things are the worst thing
on earth
what it's like yeah of course they like
don't belong on twitch as a platform but
it's not some cleavage i just don't
think it's the same as for example
violent uh chauvinism i'd much rather
see a pair of titties ten twenty that's
different
then hear that oh my god i'd rather i
want to see teddy's regardless
where the titties at why are we
complaining out here i'm confused
do some titties you know what i'm saying
yeah i just feel like they're not really
things to be wait his channel's gone
somebody's saying his channel's gone can
we confirm that sneaker yeah no
i don't know someone said they want to
report and his channel unless it
literally happened like in the last 10
minutes because i
you know
months ago
here he is
big news i don't know much about wait
that's his main channel his second
channel is the one as offending channel
the other one isn't done either the
other one is in doubt unfortunately all
right
yeah but i think that's a great thing to
hit him with it's like i am against deep
platforming i don't support andrew tay
but i roll with free speech that's what
jake paul said which i think is so funny
like you don't have a [ __ ] bro you've
never thought about free speech that was
such a disappointment i thought for once
you had like a good take and then i
found out it did not really
you see logan had a good take about it
though did you see that no i didn't uh
let me pull that up logan paul was just
straight up like yeah this guy's a
horrible influence and i think it's a
good thing he's gone i was like okay
logan okay logan
logan
wait where is it yeah his audience is a
little here uh abe just shared it yeah
he has more manosphere fans than we do
for sure i saw some people angry about
it i don't actually all the comments are
angry this guy is always going to bow
down to companies that made him a lot of
them are like dude all you're known for
is filming a dead body you shouldn't say
[ __ ]
this pathetic stand from someone who's
cancelled and given a second chance it's
like all
all that how is that related oh my god
happy birthday keanu reeves
shout out he's 56.
wow
the ageless king
and ageless king
all right so let's let's see what logan
is we're going to dive into andrew tate
i don't feel like platforming this guy
i don't feel like giving him the
blessing of being my dance partner in
the ring especially after
the social media platforms
have made it very clear how they feel
about this guy right and and i would
even i would even
i would even um put a little call out
here to like fellow creators and even jj
like
you want to re-platform this guy
anyone you want to have him on your
shows you want to you want to give him
another opportunity to speak and and
spread his agenda because um
whether you
believe it or not the [ __ ] that andrew
tate is saying will have a ripple effect
much more dangerous than you can imagine
because his narrative is truly hateful
his rhetoric has extreme negative energy
in it and it will affect impressionable
young people in a way that will not show
until years from now bro why are they in
a prohibition bar
the alcohol
dude prohibition's legal you don't have
to hide anymore
i think it's great it's kind of cool and
the thing he's saying is especially
brave because i know he has a lot of
manosphere fans
so he's sticking his neck out and i
think that's good i actually don't know
what his fan base is like but i can only
assume obviously like as a kind of men's
podcast obviously most of the
demographic i assume is also guys yeah
so i'm curious how they responded to
that
they seem angry
oh no this is twitter you should check
the actual yeah the actual video is
everybody on twitter is angry yeah
yeah
you know i think it's mike i think
mike's a good influence on logan i think
that's what it is really here's the mic
now good guy i will say
frankly speaking i didn't have the best
impression of mike until he came on your
podcast yeah a lot of people said and
then i was like okay redemption arc yeah
it really came off very well
everyone everyone likes them
would you say that mike is a dreamboat
not in the same way he's not going to
destroy my childhood and my family and
make me grow up with personality
disorders no
no
okay ethan
he has built a platform on this return
to
alpha masculine traditionalist beliefs
where
uh you know woman at center of household
uh cooking for the kids cleaning raising
the kids men at war whatever i love
cleaning i'm so good at cleaning and
he's he's been doing this rhetoric now
for a long time
the situation the issue is with all of
that is
he is not a
big
you can literally build a ship from this
[ __ ] the amount of wood at this i why
does the table soak ethan
i
wish we had a table that big
our table is too small at least they
don't have unflattering shots like that
one's too big it's not just pointed at
the bottom
yeah at least their [ __ ] guts are
obscured by this massive table
i'm like
look at these guys kirby's sitting at
the table it's okay tell me they don't
hate me
looking at this
you know i i always find these kind of
videos so
funny because
it makes me wish that i could sit at the
table and talk to them and be like
listen y'all i am someone
who
not to flex but i've made a good enough
amount of money and honestly what i need
in my life i need a stay-at-home husband
i need someone who knows how to cook i'm
clueless i need someone who knows how to
clean
i've always dreamed about being a dream
a stay-at-home husband i am the exactly
what they described straight up
i could be though ethan does cook for me
though
yeah
i could be a stay-at-home husband
yeah she's got the biggest business
i'm intimidated i need you to stay home
because i'm intimidated by your success
right and you earning your own money
removes my power over you no honestly
for me like a nice life
i i really would not mind being with
someone
and like you don't even need a
joblicious chill like when you make
money why do you have to be worried
about like gender roles or whatever like
life
let's go oh
that's what we're talking about oh my
god if you guys don't mind me just
sharing random stories i went on a date
with this guy once
first first date and you date
we met on this app that was meant to be
for like middle eastern people because i
was like i've never
i've never gone out with someone of a
similar ethnicity as me
yeah let's test it out whatever
one of the things he said was like
and i i was sure he had like googled me
or whatever
he was like i really love the idea of
like a power couple and i was like oh
okay and this is after i told him like a
business that i was going to come out
with my management agency pardon what's
his power
he sells a certain product he has an
online business okay
and he's like yeah i really love the
idea of a power couple blah blah blah
blah and i was like oh
so you like me i see i see
and then he's he says i wouldn't be okay
with someone for example just being a
hairdresser i'm not all right i was yeah
i was like what like
for someone who owns a business and
probably makes six figures plus like why
should you care at
all i think he had a really [ __ ] up
way of trying to compliment you
like a really stupid bad way to
compliment you to me i'm like damn
capitalism brainwashed you
for me if anything like and i've also
seen guys who are really really
um
like
very successful but oftentimes those
people don't have a lot of time and i
know i'm busy and i'm stressed out why
would i want to date someone who's also
busy and stressed out sure
so are we doing is this a call out to uh
the chat really is everywhere no
the chat is loving what they're hearing
and they're like marry me
looking at uh
gmail.com honestly the more money i've
accrued the less i care about money at
all at like at all i don't think it is
reflective of a person's character
whatsoever how much money they make and
i think it really bothers me when people
also because that way you've probably
like got to meet a lot of like shitty
people with money but like
disgusting people don't don't meet your
idols
and don't check who follows
entertainment
oh yeah very scary well he doesn't have
an instagram anymore so
what is your financial situation are you
set for life
uh yeah i could retire nice
there you go man set up a perfect
minute
some guys are saying like
no i'm serious pokey
they're falling in love with yourself
honestly i would even be down to have a
roommate i'm like i will pay for your
existence just hang out
i don't care if you work we're exactly
i don't know we should all just be a
little more hippie there's lots of quote
real men who are looking to uh
play video games with you in the chat
i don't want to play videos again
yeah
yes you cook and clean that's dope
because the way i view a partnership is
like you want to be able to learn from
each other grow from each other what i'm
lacking in life is definitely that
aspect
round me out a little bit
the thing is too there's no problem with
a woman as a couple deciding that she
wants to be at home and take care of
their family stuff it's the it's like
you have to do this because you're
exactly yeah
there's nothing wrong with the man doing
it either
i remember like growing up thinking to
myself when i grow up i'm gonna make my
own money oh yeah and i've always liked
like
expensive brands for clothing couldn't
afford it but i've always like dreamed
of it and i was like
i'm gonna afford my own [ __ ]
i really appreciate that my mom i feel
instilled those values in me too she's
like
always be good on your own first
i mean i'm good
yeah yeah yeah that's true
and eli you have always been like that
you've always been like a hustler
working and making your own money oh
yeah
that's why i feel like you guys deserve
all the success you have any more
more
more more
all right let's see what mike has to say
at this massive [ __ ] table what's the
echo like in that room
you know mike i love the table how do
you improve it great job how do you even
reach out to me mike i want to know who
made that table
no i want to meet that table i want to
meet that table i want to sit on that
table
in his own life he has no family he has
no wife he's 37 years old 36.
he has made the majority of his money
off of cam girls
only fans management pyramids and
casinos okay
wait is he talking about it
yeah yeah yeah
it's room it's rumored that he's
involved in casinos and the romania
mafia and all this [ __ ] i don't know
anything about that all i know is he's a
human trafficker
are she
allegedly according to an investigation
allegedly allegedly
can i just say before any andrew or
sneako fanboys come at me i don't know
much about these people they popped off
while i was gone i was just baffled to
see certain people well i'm sure they're
at home and how ugly you are yeah don't
worry they hate you already
i hope you think i'm so ugly that you
never interact with me every
yeah i hope you think i'm so ugly you
won't harass me on any platform ever
thank you
yeah no but like no but for real the the
uh
the united states government tipped off
the romanian police that he's a human
trafficking people so
hand you tate
yeah
there you have it uh very good balls
of the traditionalist mail and so my
question is my interest and my curiosity
is how can you preach a return to
traditionalism and conservatism when
your entire platform and your entire
network is based on the same things that
you preach against that's my curiosity
because that's how it makes his money
okay
oh okay okay magic white it just it gets
darker the more you listen to entertain
he's like well
she's my property
so she's doing what i tell her to do i
saw that one
yeah she's my property no but in that
moment i'm like you're you he knows he's
trolling
i don't know there's a bit trolling
intentionally trolling to like
be sensational people say that but i
think that gives him too much credit i
think he is that shitty
i think it's shitty to still say it no
matter what
my point is just like i feel like you
have to be
to really believe it i don't even think
he believes some of the stuff he says
he just keeps yeah maybe like alex jones
vibe like how he
when he mixes in what stuff like he
there's clips of him being like i don't
i only eat once a week i absorb my power
from the sun that's unlikely a joke
right but he mixes it in with the other
stuff
yeah and so yeah yeah
here's what i would look like at that
table much better this is like a kirby
super nintendo kirby is much more
flattering than jigglypuff
you know give me a [ __ ] break here
no this is an angle i can live with i
love that
yeah so he continues he says
he keeps taking my awesome quotes and
putting him out there i love that he's
like this video got a billion views by
the way this one got one point yeah
[ __ ] dude let's go baby
there's one other thing biggest podcast
on youtube
go to the podcast tab on youtube we're
number one
uh look at this is a great quote he goes
there's one thing we got to talk about
which is our very own hassan [ __ ] got
the opportunity to debate colbert the
human trafficker and that's his moniker
that's how he's known like
like alexander the great
that's the game
alex uh uh uh
jeff the donum i don't know who what are
the jokes attila the hun
hassan what attila the hun yeah the hun
and cobra tate the human trafficker
right you know it's like civ 5 it's this
his title
i gotta read this comment kirby your
enthusiasm
oh
man this was a mistake wearing this
shirt
i thought i'm gonna be supportive
i'm gonna wear the new drop no i'm
[ __ ] i love it no honestly
i think it looks great on you honestly
uh-huh no i'm serious the damage is done
they're power leveling it again over
nine thousand i think man in pink is
like an alpha move oh yeah in my opinion
i used to think that but i think men in
pink nowadays is more of a fuckboy thing
turned into like a yacht club fuckboy
thing oh oh
oh yeah because when you on f boy the
girl said that she was like that's
another sign
wearing pink used to be cool
but now it turned into like a yacht club
[ __ ] i don't know womanizer andrew
tate thing
in my experience that's right
or dbz
a lot of people saying pink's a good
color on you ethan i love the pink ethan
i like i like the pink yeah sorry
somebody called you patrick star so
but the shirt looks nice on ethan
you know all right well if you like it
so much go buy it teddy freshdog
do they describe why anything that you
said is incorrect or like show proof
yeah so they continue good question
but i like he keeps giving me shut up
he keeps saying that i called him a
human trafficker yadda yadda
the california law says i can't lie
analysis client has repeatedly false
defamatory statements about our client
to a worldwide internet audience
thank you for saying that i know
appreciate it
stated that our client is a rapist and a
human trafficker oh by the way if you
google um
andrew tate rape which you know i don't
suggest anyone do that but
oh it said he was charged he was
investigated for human trafficking and
rape right where did we see that
he also yeah
when they raided him you saw that dan
you showed me that
uh yeah um that was in the guardian
article and there was an update saying
that they had reached out to the
romanian authorities and that the
investigation is ongoing which that's
that's the thing is interesting the the
the raid that happened
he
did like a stream where he debunked it
um and claimed that he was swatted and
that the girl wasn't kidnapped she was
lying and saying that um
she only said that she was kidnapped so
she didn't get in trouble with her
boyfriend this is all his explanation
for it or whatever and then he said the
cops came they saw what was going on
they left no big deal
and all of his fans constantly repeat
that of like oh what are you talking
about he already disproved those
allegations
he can say whatever he wants he can lie
as much as he wants
the guardian reached out to the
authorities they asked about it the
investigation is still ongoing the
romanian he has not been cleared also
the u.s government is not he goes i've
been swatted that's what he says he's i
have been swatted
uh creators get swatted all the time
that's all that happened huh the united
states government reached out look at
this the romanian authorities said last
week that the investigation later
explained to cover human trafficking and
rape allegations was ongoing there it is
open well in that case i guess it's fair
to say that he is being investigated for
those things for those allegations
also when explaining why
why he moved to romania he was saying
like
well the the the rape uh laws here are a
lot loose pull it up and and he said
like his quote is i like the idea of
doing what i want
right which is like oh okay so you like
what do you think you're saying
when you say that
she described a scenario i think that
was like if a girl drinks and then she
lets you she changes her mind then she
changes her mind later which is
basically sounding to me like
he promotes oh we went back home but he
was like nope yeah and then he's like
dirty
um shaming or whatever i don't know how
to say it but it's basically sounding to
me like he may have done some let's pull
up the clip just for posterity because i
know his lawyers are watching
we do i don't want to like
end the show but we do have to be home
at a certain time that might be soon
let me keep going just cease and desist
we hereby uh request the immediate
provide evidence to us well here i'm
doing that for you
about statements made in your post
or
cease and desist legal defamation
slander or libel within the next 24
hours again i went to spam
three days
you are required to move all content and
posts across your channels that are not
limited to social media twitter youtube
which to fame
our client this action should be done in
24 hours again and went to spam i didn't
even see this for three days suck my
dick
uh you're also required to return the
signed written assurance below
affirming that you will not we haven't
even replied to him i don't care
failure to comply why does please be
guided accordingly sound religious
it's a ryan cavanaugh please yeah i
didn't notice it until i was uh
exporting all of this but the other guy
that is currently suing ethan said of
almost almost word for word the same
thing what was his govern yourself
accordingly yeah that's our next merge
yeah i think it should be guiding guide
yourself accordingly is it he said he
ends by saying failure to comply with
the cease and desist requests yada yada
will leave us no alternative but to
pursue all legal remedies come at me bro
if you refuse to return the written
assurance below our firm intends to file
a lawsuit com again i don't [ __ ] care
uh uh yadda yadda assume me i don't care
i don't give a [ __ ]
do we
should we talk about i actually should
put that on a shirt sue me i don't give
a [ __ ] yeah i assume and then like with
the number of
lawsuits you've been through
dubs yeah i mean
so far i'm 3-0
it's 3-0 that's a great record and i
still have two more open copyright and
definition defamation and maybe even a
new one coming oh this is just [ __ ] up
it's unattractive
yeah so we
looked up we love a good stock image and
it's all about crypto this is his lawyer
like the entire thing blockchain this
security crypto [ __ ] his lawyer doesn't
know anything about pioneers in online
gaming
he's probably he probably doesn't know
anything about defamation law he's
probably never even drafted a brief
about defamation in his life so i'm his
lawyer's a [ __ ] joke too
but if uh if i have any questions about
blockchain utilization i'll definitely
certainly reach out yep
um but anyway not scared don't care
um there's a couple other thing because
they asked for evidence send me the
video of him saying that he moved to
romania for rape i sent it thank you
yeah i hear pokemon maybe you can reply
and be like can you prove that these
things aren't real
yeah no
i'm not we're not responding to them if
they want to sue me they're going to
have to send the document but
you know when you want to make a real
cease and desist threat the real baller
way to do it is to attach the brief the
complaint already fully written
that's what matt haas did and that was
some real [ __ ] so we knew he was going
to sue us
so shout out to them they did they did a
you know gangster you've been through so
much
you even know that
that's the real gangster way though
you're like yo
take that [ __ ] down here's the brief
we'll file it tomorrow
just being just working with ethan for
this many years i have learned so much
more about defamation law than i thought
i ever would
yeah so he says
he goes bro what the [ __ ] i'm not like a
womanizer i i i'm not a i'm not a rapist
i mean listen
um let's see this is probably 14 of the
reason i moved to romania because in
eastern europe none of this garbage
flies if you're going to go to the
police and say he raped me back in 1988
because he should have done something
about it then you know the police to say
rain yesterday okay if you've got
physical evidence or is there cctv proof
where to happen okay let's go interview
him right now and if it wasn't really
right oh that's oh we went to the club
we got drunk she agreed to go back to my
house we started having sex and then we
carried on having sex and then we had
sex and she didn't say anything wrong
and then she texted me afterwards and i
didn't text back and now she's saying i
raped her the police was like okay she's
an idiot bye but no not in the west in
the west you can tell them that exact
story you're still [ __ ] you're [ __ ]
in the west when people say why didn't
in romania and i explained my five
reasons one of them is the metoo era
they go oh well you're a rapist i say no
i'm a [ __ ] rapist but i like the idea
of being able to just say to do what i
want i like being free and if you're a
man living in england or germany or
america or any of the western world
right now you've decided to live in a
country where any woman any ex any
[ __ ]
[ __ ] who works at greg's you bought
pasty from at some point in the future
can destroy your yeah this has obviously
happened to him a lot i'm not worried
about the girl who works at greg's
randomly accusing me of uh
it makes me so sad sometimes seeing on
the internet like
people tackle topics that deserve such
nuance
like rape allegations false or true
and then they tackle it like this
like any [ __ ] can it's like even your
rhetoric shows very clearly how you feel
yeah if you want to make a valid point
this is just not the way to do it the
way to do it is not by saying i'll do
what i want that
i don't know
yeah but my favorite part about this is
that if he does sue us the reply is
going to be full of all this heinous
[ __ ] he did and it's just going to be
the read of a lifetime
um here also he says
that he's not a human trafficker here he
says why am i an expert on all male
female interactions i've been running a
webcam studio for nearly a decade this
was on his oh he's a pickup artist this
was his website this was his land yeah
he was selling courses on how to pick up
chicks
this is what he said about himself i've
been running a webcam studio for nearly
a decade i've had over 75 girls work for
me and my business model is different
than 99 of the webcam owners over 50 of
my employees were actually my girlfriend
at a time
all of all my girlfriends none were in
the adult
entertainment industry before they met
me my job was to make women fall in love
with me i literally that was my job my
job was to meet a girl go on a few dates
leave it there see if she's quality get
her to fall in love with me and
to see where uh to see get her to where
she do anything i say and then get her
on the webcam and then we can become
rich together
whether you agree or disagree with what
i did with their loyalty submission and
love for me doesn't matter you cannot
reject the results and the results are
simple my girlfriend would do more for
me than 99.9 of men's wives do for them
this is deleted of course but we've got
the receipts
so this is a cool [ __ ] the phd
program
he's like yo my business model was
basically to manipulate and human
traffic women into my [ __ ] webcam
dungeon
i'm confused he said half of them are
his girlfriend so
did he have more than one girlfriend at
once or just
most of his girlfriends he convinced to
do it seems like they were at one time
his girl i think he's okay he's okay
with him having multiple girlfriends but
not the opposite and women can't have no
way
why he said that oh that's what you want
to see that's
he said the thing
said that that one kills me all right
one more let's just pull that one up for
pokey okay okay yeah what are we gonna
say i'll say it after yeah
yeah let's just get that one clip and
then we'll end on that
this is this is a great one yeah
we're gonna have to start the music soon
ethan just so you know
the music yeah like on the oscars where
they uh you're gonna we're gonna play
you off just give me that clip and then
you could play me off okay
not that this isn't going great we're
having a great time but you you guys
have a deadline and somewhere to be do
it though
you did we have to believe somewhere oh
[ __ ] yeah okay oh yeah our babysitter
has to leave oh
whoops okay
did you send the link
what are you looking for the video of
him saying he can date multiple women
but they i don't know if it's easy to
find yeah i mean there's such a sea of
clubs
[Music]
i feel like when i've heard that kind of
argument it's like i am a high value
they say that literally i can take care
of numerous women at
once financially and otherwise so why
you know why can't i have more
girlfriends but then it's like okay i
got my melees can i have five boyfriends
you can because everyone's cool with
that no one can't go
that sounds like a lot of work but like
does the same logic not work for women
there's nothing wrong with it in his
view curious but in his view he's saying
like and generally as a man
all men should do this and i'll want to
do this
men can't cheat he says
so a woman can't go around [ __ ]
people and pretend the same as a man
running around [ __ ] people it's
absolutely not the same if i a man can
only cheat if he loves someone else if i
have a woman who i truly love and i go
out and [ __ ] and i come back to her and
i don't care about her and i only love
my girl that's not cheating that's
exercise
if she even talks to a dude
the females are emotionally invested
i
[Music]
yeah the female human
yeah well that's about it is there
something you wanted to say
no that was really funny though
wow funny
also though why can't people just be in
open relationships we live in a day and
age where you can do so much
he can but not you you can do so much
why be so pressed if you are okay doing
that
go find someone else who is okay with
that and live a happy joyful beautiful
life well andrew you are his property
andrew knows that his dick looks like
he's been through a meat grinder and the
minute his girlfriend
sees someone with the normal looking
penis that they're going to leave him he
would never wear rick owens
oh no you couldn't pull that off
all right
guys thank you for watching pokey
welcome back to the internet thank you
so much i love all of you guys thank you
for coming i'm a great guest just
chilling with friends i would love to be
back sometime yeah great times
absolutely and thank you guys i feel
like we could keep going forever
all right have a great weekend everybody
it's friday baby
important announcement oh god did i not
say there's no showing i don't think we
did yeah we should finish labor we
should pin a couple yeah
yeah so there's no episode on monday
with peace and love i'm sorry everybody
work harder holiday
that's been that pokey once again a
pleasure and a joy
and a privilege
thank you
thank you guys for watching have a great
day bye bye have a good weekend
you're listening to the h3 podcast what
we got on the scene could it be papa
shoe nights or build elfin talking front
wiper back wife what you gonna do with
me then you know and the whole damn crew
goose and gaps with all the guests
you'll see the best podcasts in the
world take it from me jc over chair hp
baby we podcast now